To use stream.
Sorry for the the incredible delay.
Absolutely ridiculous.
I don't know why you people tolerate this shit.
I don't know why you people tolerate the shit and someone had totally dead.
Totally dead.
We have Mike stands now except for my friend John Heffron.
He's forced to hold his microphone.
Otherwise we'd you have an ungainly stand right in front of you.
I think that'd be ridiculous.
Next time we get like a stamp,
I have a stance.
I this,
I'm just gonna I'm gonna rock it out like this.
Like I'm about to bell out the last part of some song,
which was lead singer from creed.
Yeah.
I'm just going to be wrong.
So I'll,
I'll just go like this and this is perfect.
I'm probably gonna wind up holding onto the mic too.
Cause as a comic that seems like a natural thing.
This seems less natural to have this fucking thing in front of you,
right?
Yeah.
It's kind of odd.
Or those stands,
those are kind of like singer songwriter stands and we do a comedy club.
I am a singer song that I know,
but well they have to use a stand like that.
Is there anything more fucking pretentious than a singer songwriter?
Yeah,
I've done some shitty and then you've got some shitty gigs.
Like if you have like,
and this is like say as a comic,
I mean I talked about this with Tom Segura as a comic,
you have to admit that most comic suck,
right?
What are the odds?
What are the uh,
the numbers rather it's like 80% suck.
There's a lot of the,
a lot of bad,
right?
Same as the singer songwriters.
So there's cool singer songwriters,
but 80% of them are fucking miserable.
Douchebag.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen,
John has fun.
Winner of last comic standing,
miserable douchebag.
No,
great guy.
Incorrect sir.
You're incorrect about yourself.
Uh,
if you haven't seen John John One a season two of last comic standing.
I thought it was season one cause I blocked out season one cause I was on it and
I was on it with Buddy Hackett and a buddy Hackett got mad at me and then died
two weeks later I was going to yell at him.
It was a creepy moment,
man.
I think we talked about this.
Did we talk about this?
Well the last time you were on,
but a Buddy Hackett yelled at me and I almost yelled at them back and then two
weeks later he died.
So I'm glad I didn't yet.
Okay.
Do you guys know who rip torn is or rip lamp Ran Dorn Porn or whatever?
That dude,
I just saw him today.
I had breakfast and he sat in the table next to me and just freaking everybody
out and stuff.
What was he funny at one point?
I don't really know anything about him except he was always like those Hollywood
squares dudes that's always been on like Hollywood squares back in the 70s and
shit.
Right.
He was passing out flyers at Patty's and it was this really kind of just fuck
looks crazy.
Like he doesn't even look like him anymore.
Pretty scary.
How do you know it was really him?
Because he was passing out rip van torn like flyers.
You said throw the confetti was his thing
on.
I'm a guy guys with it.
That guy.
Yeah,
but he was,
that was back when there was probably just him and Hey Brian,
can you do me a favor and just shut that door.
And that other dude that was way gay that was on Hollywood squares.
Hey Samantha.
Yeah.
What is his name?
The worst impression ever.
But you know,
that's how get an impression,
because I knew exactly what you're talking about.
Uh,
Charles [inaudible] Riley.
Okay.
Maybe that was not so Riley.
No,
that was a different guy.
It doesn't nothing.
Yeah.
This guy was also on a,
uh,
bewitched Samantha.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
He said,
no,
he's,
he goes,
fuck 10 [inaudible] guys.
They were like the only two or three way,
way gay guys,
whatever.
And every TV show had him on.
Yeah.
That's so true.
If you were a gay guy back then,
man,
you had to be fucking obviously gay and never talk about it.
You know,
they never talked about their boyfriend
talk about butts sacks and what they like and what they don't like.
They just threw confetti and you went,
you know what?
That guy's throwing confetti.
He's probably gay.
You know,
it's crazy when you stop and think about how many people were like undercover
gay back in those days like rock Hudson,
you know,
so many,
so many different God.
They just couldn't,
they couldn't be themselves.
They,
they didn't have that option.
It was impossible.
You know,
or you go,
yeah,
they didn't have that option,
but they could go out and go to like a gay whatever crazy club and never get
busted.
It was a volume to ever get caught.
Yeah,
the volume on now you streams over modulating cause it's over because it's so
fucking powerful now baby.
I think that readers is that guys better.
Sorry.
There you go.
Yeah.
It used to be a terrible place and not get busted though.
That was back in the day when you left your house,
your,
your wife couldn't get a hold of you until you got back home.
So you could do gay shit.
Yeah.
So you could have a white,
how many of them are,
but now how many think we're upfront with their wives and said,
listen,
you don't have to work ever again.
I'll give you a big fat house.
You drive around a nice car.
You don't have to have a job.
I've just been my life.
You know,
you could fuck guys.
Just keep it on the DL.
Don't get me in trouble.
Do you think there was that or do you think it was that's,
that's a difficult move though,
because you've gotta be a pretty open and honest guy to like pull that
conversation off if your version,
I think that happens a lot.
I think there's a lot of beards in Hollywood.
There are,
but how many of them know their beards?
See,
I know,
I know a girl who was married to a guy for 10 fucking years and then it turns
out the guy was gay.
The guy came out 10 fucking years into their marriage and they were dating
before they were married.
So who knows how long they had been going on where he was just trying to keep it
together and pretend he was heterosexual.
And finally he just,
he just came clean.
That's crazy shit man.
And that girl was,
I know for sure,
absolutely unaware,
completely devastated.
Couldn't believe it.
Shocked,
blown away.
You know.
That's,
that's uh,
that's,
and she does a working woman.
I mean,
she works in Hollywood.
She's a smart woman.
Pretty crazy story,
man.
What I don't understand is I might gate our,
has to go off,
you know,
if I'm married to somebody,
I'm with them that much.
And if they are really gay then I,
you would think you would know unless they're really stupid.
Yes he would.
But this woman who I know is not the most sexual person and she's very ambitious
and she works the time and she maybe doesn't even like sex that much and maybe
every now and then he likes fucking girls.
You know,
maybe,
maybe he's really good at eating,
posted it,
cause he wishes he had one.
He's like,
if I had,
when I went to this to it,
but a terrible fucking gay voice,
I just threw out Josh.
So stereotypical,
I'm so embarrassed for myself.
But uh,
yeah man,
it's fucking,
it's gotta be real hard to,
to have that wacky gene and you know,
be stuck in a situation where you have to pretend that you're not,
you know,
cause you imagine if you had to pretend to be gay all the time,
imagine if the only way to work in Hollywood was he had to be gay.
So you had to run around pretending to be gay,
including dating guys and letting them fuck you.
How about that?
To add to the,
to the thing,
could you fucking imagine if that was the only way?
Could you imagine if you're a comic,
you want to make it as a comic and you,
the only way is if they think that you're gay,
right?
But it's so tempting me.
You want to be a comic so bad.
You've always wanted to be a comedian.
That's your fucking thing,
you know,
cause you imagine,
no,
Holy Shit.
You know,
we're very lucky.
So lucky to be heterosexual.
So lucky.
So true.
I mean,
except for several of the whole,
you have to worry about babies.
That's it.
Gay dudes,
they just plug each other in the ass all day and they don't have to worry about
shit.
There's no repercussions.
The worse they get,
some sort of a disease,
they get the aides.
That's the worst.
But other than that,
they're just pleasure.
It's all pleasure,
you know,
just shooting loads and each other and having a good time.
I've got online last night and uh,
I was on youtube watching that r Kelly clip,
my new favorite clip of all time and I want them to youtube journey,
which is always amazing.
If you ever like,
you should the very first video and youtube,
you should write down what it is.
Yeah.
And then backtrack your mind to see how you went from r Kelly too.
Well,
I went from r Kelly to gay bears,
Gay Muscle bears and daddy bears these,
all these,
these videos of gay guys,
these hairy gay guys have online big muscular gig guys like flexing and you read
like the fucking comments and it's hilarious.
The comments are all these gay dudes going,
Oh,
already got pre-comm and like,
you know,
my tick got hard love just looking at that.
I can't wait to shoot on his back,
you know.
Oh,
what I would do to him.
I wish I had an older man like him to molest me and I'm like,
it's all like,
you Nana Miss Perverts.
Like everyone on the fucking thing.
They're all just disgusting.
I was on wicked perverts a site,
similar,
uh,
and adult site that had comments underneath the actual porn scene,
which is just shows,
I think it's weird as a generation thing where that a new thing.
I've never seen that happen.
Where you can't use trim is normal,
but an a porn side.
Have you ever seen it?
I'm sorry.
I hate the way she sucks Dick.
She hates it.
That's what it said.
There was this one.
It was this Asian girl and she was typewriting in the comments underneath was,
why would she be using a typewriter right now?
And it's to me,
maybe it's just an aging,
but it's like just be happier seeing porn.
There's generation of guys that used to go through the weird guys trash staff to
get to Sears catalog.
We've talking about this many times,
you know,
we're sponsoring should be happy that you have porn and you really get to create
a screen name.
By the way,
we have to mention this.
We're sponsored now,
sponsored by the fleshlight.
So you're that.
That's a butt hole right there,
Fella.
Pubic hair on.
It doesn't have to be careful.
I did not.
I'm not used this one,
sir.
I need to do not use the butthole one and I would not pull out the vagina one
out of respect,
the one that I have used.
I like how it's autographed.
Yeah.
So important.
The Vagina one's autographed to really different checks.
Yeah.
I think that one's like Christopher Reeves.
That's Christopher Reeves,
butthole.
Thank you.
Than I expected.
So that's the flesh.
I,
I've watched it by it.
If you're a masturbator I know you are.
You've got to pick one of those up.
It's fucking fantastic.
The greatest masturbation tool ever invented for dudes cause for d for years do
ted nothing.
Now we have this golden 18% off on Joe's website.
Oh yeah.
You clicked on a link and get some,
get some money for it,
get some money off and you got to figure if we just go through that.
I've never used one.
But anything else you might use that is going to probably called shafing any and
it might,
you know what I mean?
You get a little hot spots here or there.
That's probably a safer thinking about that.
Thinking about the less open sores you're putting on your,
on your junk,
irritating the skin.
Look at you thinking practical lane.
That's the practical and I dunno what that means.
I know what you're fucking to put sores all over your tick.
But yes,
I agree with you.
Well I'm just saying some t shirts are softer than others.
Do you fuck your tee shirts?
So you do know.
But I'm saying it's something just so that you know,
what the fuck are you saying?
Say others don't say it.
You Fuck your tee shirts?
No wrong with that.
I don't know if I'm fat.
Basically everything I own,
I fucked my bed or fuck pillows of fuck soap.
Uh,
fuck shampoo.
I tried to difference in your soap and shampoo and my dick got irritated ones
cause I fucked this,
uh,
this soap,
but I didn't know it was Mrs Rogan soap and it was like for like if you have
acne,
and I just forwarded it on my dick and beat off with it.
And then my Dick,
oh fucking red and sore.
And I was like,
what the fuck was that shampoo?
And then I just thought it was shampoo man.
They just say through conditioning.
If I smell pert,
I start to get a little bit of roast.
Wow.
If I hear running water APP loves dogs.
Exactly.
If I smelled her.
But I think conditioners a way better way to go to champagne bubbles where your
blow bubbles,
that soap.
What's kind of oily?
And that's the best soap to fuck.
I think dudes don't have to worry about any of that shit when they're gay.
They just bang each other.
I bet gay guys hardly even jerk off.
They're just so busy banging each other.
They can just get sex all the time.
I think so I think you see it at the gym.
You just come here and just to look and then you disappear in the steam room.
I used to work out a 24 hour fitness and the guy who was the manager there was
this really cool guy and he was assigned to the West Hollywood store,
the West Hollywood 24 hour fitness.
Cause he had a clean it up,
hold on quote,
cause they were having problems there because dudes were fucking there and dues
fuck all over the place.
They would,
they would fuck in the,
and they would have to go in there and hose down the sauna.
He said it was disgusting.
You would go in there,
it would smell like ass and there'll be loads everywhere.
These guys would just bang each other and shoot loads all over the fucking
sauna.
And you'd go in there and literally it'd be a fucking biological biological
hazard and he had to clean all this stuff out and hose everything down.
He said he always caught dudes banging in there like,
oh,
those aren't some shape guys to buy.
Dude.
Gay gyms are like gay discos.
They might as well be nightclubs.
That's where they pick each other up.
When I was a,
when I was doing news radio,
I used to work out at Gold's gym,
which is on coal,
which was a total gay disco.
I mean that's all it was,
was just a bunch of gay dudes trying to pick each other up and they would spot
you like when you didn't need a spot,
they would come over and they can stand it back down with your ball's above your
head and they would like be really aggressive like the way stared at you and
looked at you because they were used to getting their dick sucked and they did
that,
you know,
it's like that's their spot.
That's where they go,
man,
they're fucking freaks.
They don't have to worry about babies.
You know?
What was life like before the pill?
Could you imagine if we grew up being one,
was the pill,
the 50s is that what it was?
Could you imagine if we grew up when there was no pill?
We don't even know what that's like.
My girlfriend was on the pill when she was 16 right when I was 16 or I was 17
she was 16 she was on the pill.
I don't know what it's like to be in an error when there was no pill.
Could you imagine how much more careful you had to be?
How trickier it had to be,
you know?
Yeah.
Or were guys then or are they were like kind of dudes now when you're just
whatever.
Out of a hundred out of a hundred people,
guess how many per year?
At 100 people I get pregnant even while they're on the pill.
How many?
83% per air protected.
So it's whatever.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's only 83% so 17% so 17 out of a hundred really?
It was just that planned parenthood the other day,
so they really said that.
You know why?
Because show you that on that of that 17%,
99% of those 70% are lying whores.
Yeah.
That's why I totally on the pill.
Yeah,
you're on the pill.
Yeah.
You shoot a load in there.
Now you have a baby,
right?
I have a new baby.
Oh yeah.
How is it going?
How's your questionnaire?
Justice?
My uh,
Mrs Rogan gave birth on a Wednesday.
We have a new baby and don't read the chat.
You're going to get distracted,
son saying you're not even paying attention readings or your lost.
Sorry that.
Don't want to read that.
I'm just going to concentrate on the conversation.
I'm going to tell you not to chime in.
You don't have hair chime in.
Random random random dude.
You gave a voice to some douchebag,
some asshole out.
They look.
The beautiful thing about the Internet I always say is that anyone can say
anything.
They all are free to say whatever they want.
But the horrible thing about the Internet is it anyone could say everything,
right?
They can say whatever they want.
So douche bags get to talk to.
So you don't know what kind of group you're getting and you can't read the
negative shit.
99% of it is going to be cool people with questions,
but that 1%,
you can't respond to them because then you'll be enforcing shitty behavior.
Yeah.
You know,
those faggots need to get a life,
those fucking dummies that want to come on and talk shit and they want to do it
on Twitter and they want to do it on my space and Facebook there though.
I had to learn the hard way that you're supposed to ignore them,
you know?
Yeah.
Or joke about it.
It is hard because you see him like,
fuck you.
But that's not even a person,
man.
That's a sad little blip of energy,
of negative energy.
I had this fucking dude,
I should read it because it's that interesting.
I had this fucking dude that sent me a message about,
um,
the woman who,
uh,
I had an argument with this feminist woman wants on,
um,
on my space and uh,
not in my space on,
um,
it,
they put it up on Youtube.
Kevin,
Kevin Booth filmed it.
It was behind the comedy store's Lady Lydia lunch.
And I tried to be nice to her,
but she got like super aggro with me and really do she and said she was going to
burn me with her cigarette.
So I just started fucking ripping her apart and it's on youtube and this guy
sent me this fucking scathing.
I mean that the chick is a cunt.
Okay.
There's no way I would ever yell at a woman unless that woman's a con.
I mean it has to get to a a dirty,
horrible.
If that's my manager,
I'm fucking firing them.
I swear to God.
Well,
I got a,
yes it is.
I'm doing my podcast.
It's Wednesday.
Today's Wednesday,
Tuesday,
whatever it is.
That's a real comic.
I don't even know what fucking day.
Meanwhile,
they were,
they were getting mad because we were talking about them in the flashlight.
We're not allowed to talk about them anymore.
Anyway,
so this fucking guy sent me this,
this email back.
I mean,
the first email he sent me was like really fucked up,
like just such a Douche bag.
That woman you bullied on Youtube.
Let's just listen to this.
This woman is an ass,
but Joe Rogan looks like a typical dude who would be on Jersey shore pushing and
punching bullying woman physically.
Okay.
I didn't bully or I told him not to touch my face.
She touched my face and I pushed her hand away from me while,
dude,
you're so tough,
man.
What a funny faggot you are.
Talk about mommy issues.
Christ.
How do you live each day being such a miserable bitch?
Typical low file pig,
only other short,
ugly,
miserable potheads with the inhale.
Think all this fucking energy and this keeps going on and on and on and on.
Uneducated piece of trash.
Instead of telling us that you wish the president would take mushroom trips,
try living life without smoking joints.
You Pothead burnout.
Fucking dumb dumb.
So this is obviously someone who's been to my show.
So cause I say the president should take mushrooms.
I've said that in my act.
So this is obviously probably some Hackler,
probably some dude got jacked at one of the shows.
Um,
and then I sent him some message.
I think I sent him something like,
uh,
I said that,
hey,
this is what I said,
if that's what you got out of the video,
then you deserve be the type of person that writes such a retarded email.
You have created your own reality and the sucks to be you kisses.
So that's,
that's,
I said to him,
I don't know why I did it because I shouldn't have,
because when you do that,
what happens is you create a fucking battle,
you know,
for no reason.
So this fucking guy writes this thing that's like paragraphs long.
You're the typical jersey shore,
hostile short dude.
You'd like to believe you are different because you move to plastic land with
the fakes.
But it just goes on and on and on and it's so fucking sad.
And I,
I look at stuff like that and I say,
here's a guy that obviously not a happy person.
There's no way he successful Michael Jordan's not sitting around you Ustream,
you know,
writing letters like this or on Youtube or whatever.
These are all go Jordan.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
It's done.
There's no winners out there.
Should Donald Trump stop getting on fucking my space and shit.
Not Bands.
Your bad shops.
You guys are faggots.
You know it's always some fucking zero.
But the amount of hate that someone would generate and all of it comes from them
not being happy with who they are.
All of it.
100% if they want to put out that much energy.
I mean you could have disliked for someone and you could disagree with someone,
but if you're,
you spill out so much vial and it's about something that had nothing to do with
you.
What you're doing is finding someone who you don't like to compare yourself to.
They're got something that makes you uncomfortable,
whether it's success or looks or money or whatever the fuck it is.
You know they're doing something you don't,
that you wish you were doing.
You know they are getting attention.
You wish you were getting.
That's all it is.
So you have to treat them instead of like human beings.
You have to treat them like these little aberrations,
little blips of energy and you've got to learn from them.
So when you see some Douche bag,
they like chimes in and says something fucked up the way you have to look at
these people.
And it's almost like the sad little creatures like trapped and like a,
like a jail of their own choosing,
you know,
so don't respond.
Yeah.
I just got,
I got an email a few days ago that literally said,
you know,
I just saw your special on comedy central.
You are one of those guys where your parents must have told you you were funny
even though you weren't in.
And then he goes on to say,
you know,
you,
you suck.
You're not funny.
You'd maybe make a good weather guy,
Bubba,
bubba.
So then I saw that actually kind of funny.
You might be making good weather guy.
I'm not saying this suck a comic,
but I believe that if you set a storm front was coming in.
Um,
but then I was like,
at first I got mad and wanted to respond to the guy and then I went,
you know what,
how many emails do I get from people that were like,
that was the greatest show ever.
And I don't even think about responding exactly that
because,
and,
and what's that guy's focus like?
There's not been what?
Like you just said,
one band that I've hated so much that I went to their website,
logged in and said,
I just want to,
you'll never coming.
See,
you know,
artists,
no rider,
no comic.
Never.
I've never done that to anybody online that I did.
If I didn't like their stuff,
I didn't like it.
No.
I might comment on Twitter.
I thought that movie socks,
you know,
but,
but writing someone like some fucking horrible scathing evil email like that,
that's only the second year to apply to it.
Their heart would check cause they were excited that,
oh and then it's on this guy that I told you that I sent that email back.
He wrote me fucking paragraphs.
That douche bag probably spent hours of that.
Meanwhile,
he's probably unemployed and his life's in fucking shambles.
12 years old and he pees himself still and he has a computer and he's making fun
of all of us.
That's the prime I hate.
Like I got in a fight with somebody the other day,
I like back and forth and then I went to his myspace page and it was like a kid,
like he had Pokemon is one of his favorites and I'm like,
God,
I'm even wasting time on this kid.
Well it's possible.
It's always possible that the little teenagers,
but yeah,
the more,
the more important thing is that what it is is it's not a person and you think
it's a person because you know like in real life,
if someone did that to you,
it would cause like a real situation.
You'd be like,
wow,
there's like some negative energy going back and forth between me and this
person,
but you're not even making physical contact with that person.
So you got to learn how to like not accepted.
Like when shit comes in and it's like anonymous shit on the Internet,
you got to learn how to not accept that.
It's a difficult thing.
Right?
It's tricky.
This is probably the trickiest thing about being in the,
you know,
quote unquote public eye,
is,
is dealing with all the losers,
all the fucking failures,
all the shitty human beings that just want to dump on people and it's easier to
dump on people.
If you do that all day,
then you never have to look at what's going on with your own life.
You were like,
I've had a busy day short 10 bands that I hate and five comics I can't stand.
Wow.
This guy,
I went to a youtube page two,
which is even more hilarious because it's just filled with people shitting on
him,
calling him an asshole.
So I guess he just does this constantly,
just that's what he does.
Just fucks with people.
And um,
I,
I thought it was,
it's fascinating,
man.
It's fascinating that there's people like that that for sure our fucking losers,
not a single one of these guys is successful,
is doing what they want to be doing because if they were to be concentrating on
that,
I don't have enough energy out there to concentrate on some other shit.
I don't have any energy to go out there and try to bring someone down for no
reason.
I don't have it.
I don't have it to give and if you have it to give for sure you're missing
something in your life.
Apps a fucking lutely you miss.
It cheats us.
I've been following a lot of Christians on,
on the Twitter lately.
Oh,
so this brings me back to our Kelly.
Before I went,
we went gay guys,
gay guys.
Big Bear to r Kelly.
Okay,
you fucking have to see this r Kelly clip.
I got to show you this video because this is the best piece of unintentional
comedy I've ever been a witness to its r Kelly and it's a video called real talk
and I watched it.
I'm not bullshitting you man.
I watched it fucking 10 times yesterday.
I'm going to find it here on your Twitter.
Yep.
Here it is.
Can um,
can I play it here?
How's the volume thing working?
I'll,
I'll do the volume
thing on this computer.
Okay,
here we go.
That's fine.
Is it?
It's on my Twitter.
You're not even on my Twitter faggot.
Okay,
now you are.
I had to meet the other thing.
Oh my God.
You're fucking ridiculous.
Scroll down.
All right.
Right there.
Okay.
Scroll up.
Jesus Christ.
Can you fucking read?
So scroll down all the way,
man.
No,
it's true.
Derek.
Damn.
You freaked out.
I watch some link that you hit yesterday,
but some guy in call,
I watched the whole thing.
Okay.
You gotta crank crank this up.
I think it's a great song.
You know what?
This is our Kelly,
who's my favorite unintentional black comedian.
How real she gives when you arguing with your girl Miss Shit,
you got upset.
So I did it on Youtube.
Y'All on youtube.
Real talk.
Behind the scenes is what it's called on to close.
We got stone.
He's jumping off here.
Now what it is,
is our Kelly have any argument with this check?
Turned it into a song.
I'm doing this for the fans.
It's a no,
just a conversation with him and he's checking the love.
Real talk.
Calm down.
I was at a club.
Good
man.
Girl.
I'm not about to sit up here and argue with you about the blame
thing I'm trying to establish with juicing stablish right.
Meanwhile,
while he's talking to close with some model
slogan,
intriguing and kick in the tail,
because did she say,
oh look,
I have,
but she stayed.
There were other guys there.
Well,
the other guys will tell me this.
How the fuck she know I was with them?
All the dirt.
I love how there's no point cause he's got this intelligence
was the other guys.
He's got a fucking rock solid.
Excuse me.
Why are you jealous?
No Man,
I don't know why you fuck with all them jealous.
No Man.
And have an assholes anyway.
Don't you think I got another bullshit?
Did Not just give you money to go get your hair tools and nails.
Don't know the day your way for smiling.
I'm gonna have to deal with if he was out with no,
it gets better I think,
Dave.
Nobody.
Nothing.
No money.
See what your problem.
It is always running off at the mouth telling your your mother fucking
days.
They
don't make us
real tall.
Can Watch your mouth.
This is I want you talking about are so good as bull shit.
I'm coming home and getting my shit and get the fuck about her dog
and the next time your last get horny called fuck while you're
probably already doing that shit.
Ooh,
he's sitting.
That's the end of it.
And there's like a fake fight afterwards.
He's singing through a ghetto argument.
What his girl and he's singing like with passion and I wish you well.
My mother fucking clothes.
We'll talk.
Everybody listening next time you fight with your girl,
you have to just throw the word.
We'll talk into the conversation.
Oh my God,
that's good.
He likes it.
He likes to pee on girls too,
which is funny.
Yes.
You did not see the vision.
Did he not get acquitted?
You don't want to get sued.
I've seen the video.
She best watch him run the,
he got his jacket and he got to be dazzled at the mall.
Did you see that?
He had like this little jewels you put on cell phones all over his dad.
I don't know why you're hanging out with all them.
No Man having assholes.
Anyway,
we'll talk.
I want to see him and easy.
He deep kiss.
What are you talking about?
He's fucking awesome.
He's,
he is a dude out there working for you.
Okay.
That guy is providing you on the entertainment.
You don't look,
you might not like him.
You might think he's stupid,
but dad was goddamn entertaining for all the wrong reasons.
Yeah,
but that was goddamn entertained.
That easily could have been a sketch on the Chappelle show.
Oh,
it was awesome.
For the wrong reasons.
Yeah.
I liked his,
wrote a thought though when the guy was like,
you were out within,
I had girls,
he didn't,
I buy you something yesterday.
Right.
You're happy then.
So wait,
did notice by your love the fucking pause where there's no music is,
did she say there were other guys there?
Did she say that were other guys,
I wish you would burn my clothes.
And it sounds like you said he was gonna shoot her then bailed and realized.
I mean some bad's going to happen to what they eat.
Don't make a shit.
That's a song.
That's genius shit.
But you know,
you could say,
let this idiot,
this moron,
but listen,
that guy is giving massive amounts of unintentional comedy.
Yeah.
You know
closet.
Yeah.
He's always been great too.
Yeah,
I love him.
Fucking hilarious.
Trapped in the closet was one of the best ever because it was like,
what?
Seven parts or something like that and more than that,
like 24 ports.
So fucking DVD,
dude.
I got a DVD of it.
It might be a two fucking DVD set.
I want to watch that in three D.
Yeah.
I watched this all day yesterday.
I just kept watching it over and over and over again.
I literally watched it 10 times.
That's awesome.
Talk.
It's genius.
Genius Shit.
All right.
Anyway,
back to
pretty Murphy's has been died.
Isn't that ridiculous?
Crazy.
Never figured that guy would be out there jogging the,
is it a heart attack or drugs?
Drugs.
Yeah,
that's what they're saying.
Hmm.
I mean,
it ain't wheat grass juice to killed that fat.
Fuck.
I mean,
look at them.
Everybody was wondering why,
how that really knocks you on and what the protein drink or do.
This is how you have to look at it.
You see
guy who's that fucking fat with a movie,
Star Hottie for a wife and she's got a drug problem.
Well,
that's where fucking drugs are coming from.
They're coming from the fat guy.
It's,
I mean,
it doesn't take Sherlock Holmes to figure that one out.
That's pretty simple.
Yeah,
man,
that's a big problem out here,
isn't it?
The prescription drugs,
drugs are a huge problem in Hollywood and prescription drugs are the most,
the biggest one.
That's the one that doesn't get talked about.
Everybody's on pills.
I can't tell you how many times someone has offered me oxies people have offered
me vicodins people who offered me Xanax is just offering them like,
you want some gum?
Hey,
you want a viking in you want,
you want,
you want a prescription drug,
you want some oxies fucking yeah.
Axes where people are giving out heroin.
Whoa.
Giving out any next cm,
let me know that stomach acid medication.
It's scary,
dude.
It's scary.
Bring in humans
beings into this world knowing that it's just going to get more and more fucking
crazy.
So a baby Rogan number two was just pouring the other day.
And uh,
this was the craziest part of the,
the bear,
the birth process.
The birth process is totally normal.
You know,
it's all great and everything baby comes out beautiful,
everything's healthy,
everyone's happy.
But when a check gives birth to a baby and the baby comes out of her pussy,
it tears her taint.
It tears the,
the,
the line between the,
the butthole and the VJ J and they have to so shop tainted love.
So the baby comes out okay.
And the doctor has the baby.
I cut the cord,
everything's happy,
we'd take the baby,
the baby goes to the,
to the incubator where they have to,
uh,
you know,
clean it up and all that jazz.
So while this is all happening and the doctor starts stitching,
okay,
you watch wife is holding the baby.
Okay,
my wife's holding the baby and she's so happy,
but she had an epidural so she's numb from the waist down.
So she's got this epidural,
she's not feeling shit and she's happy and Smiley and she's holding the baby.
Meanwhile,
her legs are up in the stirrups and her vagina is fucking scene from hell
raiser.
This dude is just hooks and pulling and hooks and pulling just fish hooks just
digging into me and it's not like one or two times.
He's fucking getting in there.
He wants it tight in that shit up for me and extra for a couple more stitches.
No,
he's doing,
he's like an old joke between men.
You know,
doctors are 20 but a couple of extra stitches.
But no dude,
he is just digging in.
But it was so surreal watching the scene because on one hand,
here's my wife with this new baby and she's super excited and there's so much
love in the air and the baby's crying and nuzzling up with her and you know,
and there's tears coming down her face and she's so happy and this huge smile
and then three feet below that is a fucking horror movie.
I mean they're just hooks,
hooks,
hooks.
Wow.
Yeah Dude.
And then she has to wear a diaper cause you know,
it's all,
it's blood and the whole area's a mess.
So she's got these crazy granny panties on with this big like giant Super Maxi
pad diaper type thing.
Stuffed nice to her pussy.
Are we doing this now?
We're going to sit back.
I feel very uncomfortable or comfortable perspective.
But you're supposed to,
everything I've read nothing I have no,
but you're supposed to never look right as it did.
Say that.
I love that.
No,
no,
not below the curtain.
Didn't bother me at all really the first time.
No,
I mean it's,
it's natural man.
It's part of life.
And I did the stitches has come up by themselves or did they have to get,
yeah,
absorb.
What's that?
Who passes out?
Cause even you telling that story,
that's why lean back.
I'm like real shit dude.
I might pass out from is a lot of trauma.
You know,
I thought about that the other day.
Like you know,
like a fireman or a policeman.
They've seen way more trauma than right.
You know,
they,
they see a lot more crazy shit than I do.
But compared to the average person,
I mean almost every week I see somebody who,
but again,
Jack fucking senseless,
like almost every week I'm so oblivious to that.
Like when I see like fights break out at clubs or something like that,
I mean I always get like,
all right,
am I want to get the fuck outta here,
but I never get like uncomfortable.
I'm like,
I see,
I see this all the time.
Like I'm always seeing broken bones and giant fucking facial gashes and blood
everywhere.
So I'm watching this with this clinical disconnect while this guy is digging
fucking hooks.
It's like pinhead.
What was the one where the skin was stretched back?
That's what it's like
and he's going in there and he and he had to change hoax at one time to get a
bigger hook to go deeper because they do levels because the whole team is like
ripped apart.
The fucking babies got my head's big fucking head baby and fucker and it just,
reps just tears open.
Yeah,
Dude.
It's extreme shit.
And then after the baby's up,
they
pull this placenta bag out and the placenta bag,
this is where the baby,
you know this is the sack where the baby was living,
you know,
to eat.
No,
they pull it out.
Do they pull it out and it's like,
it's like an alien.
It's like some alien creatures like an octopus was living in any girls.
Yeah.
It's funny.
They cook it up very strange.
Yeah.
They fry it with eggs.
They fry rather like eggs.
I keep doing that,
which is probably very annoying.
Financials,
it's what?
Bananas or something I couldn't stop saying the other day.
Sometimes I get a word in my head like that is fucking bananas.
And it just gets stuck and it got stuck for like the whole two hour podcasts.
So anyway,
my advice to you is,
uh,
don't look below the curtain.
You should look,
you should look,
you should know what the fuck is going on.
Yeah.
Probably got to be able to handle it as a,
as a human,
as a man as
well.
There's nothing like that.
You ever prepared for it,
you know,
so,
I mean,
I could probably watch fights all day long.
Well,
you,
you have a stepdaughter,
you ever thought about shooting a live one into the message and making a,
making a real one.
We've never not tried,
obviously.
You know,
so you have tried.
Yeah,
I've never not,
you know,
but you've been trying to have a baby this whole time.
You were there.
What,
five years now?
Wow.
I don't know how,
but then I'm like,
well,
I travel all the time and then I hear you.
You're knocking them out.
Everything or,
yeah.
Well.
And I do are,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think I travel more than you do.
Um,
are you,
um,
getting your balls check during?
I got it.
Got that thing.
Whatever the number is.
It's like 22 million is average.
Like I had like I was in the sixties or seventies.
So you're good.
Yeah.
So she's got a broken box or something or I'm never home that,
that I don't understand.
Cause then I watch like the,
have you ever fucked her 30 days in a row?
No.
Welcome to marriage,
ladies and gentlemen.
I know all you people out there fucking girlfriend three times a day I
got married.
Yeah it would.
Yeah,
you're gonna,
you're gonna stop fucking your wife.
So horrible for me.
Somebody Wednesday through Sunday,
you know,
some months or less than others.
How much do you think?
It's a lot,
but you want to freeze your loads.
I'm thinking lately if it's,
if everything adds up,
why not just free sperm,
get your shit snipped and then now I have to do,
you're fucking sperm gets all thought out one day,
whatever.
You put it in two separate locations,
like mom's fridge in Ohio and then some science lab in California.
Okay.
I guess she's Mommy's fridge.
I know the stem cells are babies prompts.
Fridge was shitty.
It wasn't totally frozen together to have some half.
He smells like otter pops.
I used to have,
I have a
joke about that there's,
there was a group that was trying to take a,
it was the second coming project.
They were trying to take a DNA from the shroud of turn,
you know the shroud of Turin is supposed to be the,
the cloth that covered Jesus and they were going to take DNA from the shroud of
Turin and do a clone of Jesus.
They're going to make a clone and,
and give birth is clone baby.
And that would be the messiah.
They would bring Jesus back to life with technology.
And I was like,
that's all well and good.
But the technology behind cloning is not been perfected yet.
I mean like when they made Dolly the sheep Dolly's fucking dead,
you know.
And there's a lot of things that they make that come out all fucked up and they
die.
Like what if they made a retarded Jesus?
Like that was the joke.
It's like if Jesus came back and they gave birth to him,
but he had down syndrome
like would they still follow him?
He just wants to go bowling and the joke,
the joke was like,
he's the messiah duties,
fucking shitting his pants.
He's drawing all over.
It might be a test.
It might be a test screen that joke back.
Yeah.
Instead of turning water into wine,
he would turn like catch it into cookies and the cookies.
He drools all over his cookies and make sure nobody else eats him.
That's what he's the messiah instead of crosses everybody be wearing helmets.
Look bad.
If there was really,
if they really knew for sure that they had something that had the blood of
Christ on it and they knew that there was some technology,
I guarantee you there'd be some Wackos that would be convinced that that would
be the way that Jesus,
would it be coming back.
It was like they were supposed to do it.
And that is how,
you know,
it's through technology that the Christ manifest itself in this,
in this dimension and this,
this time and era.
There's a lot of people that we believe that there's,
I'm falling some guys on Twitter right now,
some creationists,
my fucking God,
their arguments are scary.
Um,
just listen to them talk about these.
I'm following dudes that think the earth is 10,000 years old and they get in
arguments all day with people.
Their entire day is,
consisted of,
consists of arguing with people about the origins of the earth,
about how old the earth is,
and about how complex cells are and how these things would be impossible to
create a just random,
I love people like that.
That's when he jumped on and go,
yeah,
Jesus was an operating system and you just fuck with him.
You know,
go crazy and just troll with them and act like you're being serious as the piss
them off.
Do you?
Uh,
I don't act like I'm being serious.
I don't,
I don't troll them either.
Most of the time I,
I just read it.
I like,
I like listening to people when they have the real arguments,
when they get really angry,
like really go back and forth to each other about shit that you don't have a
goddamn clue about.
Like you're telling me that the human eye is too complex.
So that's why there's a god,
like really for real.
That's their argument.
What a nutty ass fucking argument that it's too complicated for my stupid ass.
I don't understand how it works.
So there must be a god.
And meanwhile they just created the first artificial cell.
Have you,
did you read about that?
They made a synthetic cell.
They made the very first synthetic cell,
which is the beginning of us creating life,
which is what supposedly God did.
Look,
if human beings evolve,
if we're,
we're at right now,
if we live
in managed not to blow ourselves up or hit peak oil or whatever,
and a hundred million years from now,
we're still here.
How much more fucking advanced are we going to be than we are right now?
I mean,
what we can do right now if we can make an artificial cell right now,
if we could put satellites into orbit,
transmit data wirelessly across the entire planet,
instantly,
what kind of insane innovations are we going to have a million years from now,
10 million years,
a hundred million years will be a undiscernible from God's will be able to
create our own universes.
We'll be able to literally create our own dimensions,
our own universes.
There will be scientists that figure out ways to break boundaries through this
world and into the next fucking wormholes through space and time.
All that shit is going to happen.
You know,
all that shit is on the way.
Oh,
100% so how the fuck do you know that that's not what there's,
there's a lot of scientists that absolutely believed that the universe that we
live in May very well be just some sort of model that's being run by some super
intelligent being
that we literally,
we are,
we are running inside like some sort of a system though.
Scientists love smoking pot.
The most sciences do.
Dude,
Carl Sagan was a huge pothead.
Why would you not be a pothead if you're a scientist?
Scientists are supposed to be thinking about sitting,
sitting around thinking about cool shit.
Right?
Right.
Why would you not want to behind when you're thinking about cool shit?
Like if you watch us space,
documentary space.
Documentaries are my favorite things to watch.
I love watching space documents cause it's just,
they just put it all in perspective.
Like sometimes you have to watch them two or three times to really get what
they're saying cause it's so fucked up.
But when you watch him sober,
they're not nearly as interesting when you watch him high on weed,
we give it,
try it on weed.
If you do it on smoking pot and watches,
pick documentaries.
You know Carl Sagan used to smoke weed every fucking day.
Carl Sagan,
his thing was he would smoke pot and that's where he get his ideas from.
I mean he wrote about my signature on the broken board is all Carl Sagan sent.
You know?
Yeah.
My problem though with watching these documentaries,
like you just had me watch a documentary,
the collapse collapse,
and my problem with these documentaries is it just takes one little thing for me
to just get thrown off the tracks and believe in belief.
You know,
you don't have to believe in documentary,
so I don't,
I don't believe most of the documentaries I,
I listened to her watch.
What I do is I just tried to see,
even at this guy's wrong about a lot of shit.
Does he have points?
Because I know a lot of people who are wrong about a lot of shit,
but every now and then they'll say something like,
okay,
here's a perfect example,
Alex Jones.
Alex Jones is not right all the time.
He's just not.
Some of the stuff that he believes is fucking crazy and I don't understand it.
I listened to him and I see the connections that he's making when he says that
he's got proof and we have the documents and Alex is a friend of mine and I love
the guy but I listened to his connections and I'm like,
Oh this is a logical,
this is your,
your you want to come to this conclusion and that's how you found it.
But every now and then he'll sell more than every now and then a lot he'll say
shit that I know is right.
I mean just facts.
Yeah.
But
the problem is is a lot of these people are using how they present these facts,
quote unquote is almost like a used car salesman trying to sell you,
you know jelly beans.
It's like,
like,
like this guy last night he was saying things and I was going to use Carswell's
in 1940 yeah,
car salesman is trying to fuck you
and sell you a car buddy.
Like I was having a problem with the documentary you watched last night because
he was saying a lot of things and I'm like that could,
that that really true.
And like,
I like how he said I was kind of like,
he said that weird,
does that mean that's not true or not?
And then I researched it last night and he actually does known for that guy for
saying things like,
like a news,
like a news report had something on about safe oil.
Then he would say even Fox News has reported on it,
you know,
and how he's saying it,
it gives you the impression that they were right about what they're reported on.
But they're not,
they just reported on it.
But you,
he says it's so fast,
kind of like a used car sales man that you're kind of just subconsciously going,
oh no.
The News reported on it.
You know,
he's a very
pelling speaker and what we're talking about is the,
uh,
the Michael Rupert movie and it's called collapse and what it's all about,
it's about peak oil and it's all about how the world is going to fall apart
because they're going to run out of oil and will now have no way to get goods to
people and groceries and shit.
And there'd be no way to get around.
We can't manufacture anything because everything's made with plastic.
And another thing like,
Eh,
all right.
So I was thinking this the whole time I'm watching the documentary.
Denny said something I blatantly knew he was lying on and I'm like,
no,
blatantly knew.
He knew he was blatantly lie.
I put that word in front of us that's more important.
So he said,
he said that cell phone companies have been slipping on maintenance of their
towers and all time high and that they're all the,
the cell phone towers,
uh,
not getting maintenance.
Uh,
and there,
yes.
And that pretty soon we are going to have even worse cell phone coverage.
I know for a fact that right now at and t,
Verizon,
everything are on so on top of their game when it comes to cell phone towers and
maintenance and repairs and building their systems up at third,
the highest they've ever been in that.
And I have a app on my iPhone called at and t mark the spot.
Every time I get a dropped call or have problems with my service,
it automatically Geo tags the location that you're at and it sends it to a t and
t so they have it on their file so they know where the towers towers are doing
bat.
I've been doing that ever since the APP came out the other day.
They sent me an email to our text message out of the Blue Goin,
hey,
just so you know,
we've been getting all your reports and thank you because of your reports,
we've decided to build a new tower by your house.
It will be in effect in the next two months.
Thank you for using,
continuing to use this application.
It really helps us out a lot.
And so right there,
I can tell you right now,
that's something they didn't do five years ago on at and t's network.
You know,
I was having bad servers there five years ago.
I'm screwed.
I know for a fact that that statement alone that that he made in that
documentary was bullshit and so that means everything
else that he's doing when he's crying and petting his dog.
And acting like a,
some kind of faggot.
Like I know I can't,
I can't believe anything that guy says,
well,
it gets even better.
Here's where it gets better.
First of all,
you gave you pet your dog.
he was a,
he,
he lost a sexual harassment suit,
$125,000 and whatever back wages.
So while it'd be like $127,000 from some woman who was a working for him,
uh,
he,
made a sexual advance and showed up at the door in his underwear.
That's awesome.
That was like his move.
And she freaked out and she's like,
I don't want any part of this.
So she,
uh,
she got rid of him,
or she,
uh,
told them she's not going to fuck him.
And he fired her.
And so she sued and she won.
She won $125,000.
So this guy's,
you know,
fuck financially because of that.
But the type of person that does that,
that first of all tries to fuck their employees at like 50 something years old.
All right.
This ain't a 20 year old kid and just like taking a while chance somebody gives
him some shitty advice.
Like maybe she just whip your dick out.
Really?
Sure.
Like I know how to give people that advice before and you fucking hear from
their friends,
you know,
the next day,
dude,
the fuck told me to pull my dick out.
She fucking screamed and called the cops.
I'm like,
Whoa,
you gotta know when to pull your dick out.
You can't just pull it out with everybody.
Crazy.
Fuck.
That was the move that my roommates in college,
I always did.
I never had the guts to do it,
but he said,
if the girl won't hook up with you like you're making out,
you're on the things,
pull it out and start beating off and that she's eating into your two things.
She's either going to one going to help you or to be so offended and leave,
but you kind of swing in for that other 50% is taking a chance.
You gotta know who you're taking the chance with though,
right.
And you don't do it with a chick is fucking working for you like this crazy ass
hole.
Another thing about the movie that drove me nuts was him talking about how he
just likes to go on long walks with his dogs.
Like,
dude,
you just talked about the end of fucking civilization.
People are going to starve to death for an hour and a half.
Why?
Because you're telling cigarettes.
Yeah.
While you're smoking cigarettes,
like a retard.
That's another thing I was going to get into that too.
Look,
you might be intelligent and smoked cigarettes,
but that is a fucking stupid thing to do.
Smoking cigarettes is something that everyone with a brain should figure it out.
Yeah,
we should get,
so when you're talking about the end of the road talking about the end of
civilization,
people are going to suffer me ma,
but dude,
you're going to rot out from the inside real soon.
You're in your 50s and your fucking chain smoking while you talk right in here.
You're giving this doom and gloom lecture and he's got his dog comes over to him
and he's like,
I just like to go on walks with my dog.
I'm like,
this mother fucker's like a character in a movie.
He's like a character in a Jack London book.
You know?
It's like the man who knows about it and all he does,
he goes on walks,
she stopped blogging about it anymore is not writing.
He's just preparing for the collapse.
Like so I saw that and I'm like,
this guy is all doom and gloom and it has a vested interest.
The other thing that I didn't like is how,
how much pride he took in being right about past things that fucked up.
Oh,
we were so right.
We so nailed down this douche
bag.
A lot of people saw the fucking housing bubble asshole.
A lot of people saw that there was going to be an economic collapse.
You're not the only person that predicted the fucking stock market was gonna
crash because of an overinflated housing market because of all the fucking,
the interest that's out there right now that people can't pay off and crazy
fucking credit card debt and all sorts of bullshit that's going on in Wall
Street and
Paul knew that was happening.
Imagine the shit that cut from that interview,
you know he was,
there was probably one time we started taking off his clothes and asking for
massages from the camera guy and stuff.
There was probably all like a ton of shit that he was saying that when you think
you're just getting out of line,
this thing,
that guy was,
I could just could not believe a word that dude was saying about it or something
about it.
And then so I go on,
I go,
okay,
now I have to find out is peak oil real thing,
is there some debate of whether peak oil is a real thing?
So I go online and I see this geologist has a boy on the way
for what people don't know.
A peak oil is the point of oil.
Where's the top,
like the highest amount of oil will ever have in this,
in this country or in the world.
So once we're at the ducks,
it reaches a peak and then a decline.
So there will be less and less oil and it'll get to a point of eventually we
will run out of oil until we can make oil.
Yes.
Well what this guy was saying in the Ted talk,
and Ted,
if you don't know,
I don't remember what the acronym Ted stands for,
but the,
the TD talks online are all these like super intelligent genius fucking I get
lost on there.
And they taught us talking about different,
different subjects.
And one of them last night,
it was a guy who's talking about oil and the fucking trillions and trillions of
barrels of oil that we have discovered over the world.
And that geologists know exactly where it is and that we just have to,
you know,
figure out ways to get it from all these different places.
So I'm listening to this guy and he's like,
we're not going to run out of oil.
What we're going to do is eventually we're going to come up with something that
can replace oil and the his,
his arguments kind of weird too.
He said the Stone Age did not end because we ran out of stones.
Yeah,
I thought that was kind of okay.
I see what you're saying,
but that's fucking dumb.
Of course.
With stones don't power anything stupid,
you know,
like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like stones using to make things.
Okay.
Yeah,
I see your point.
But look,
this is a lot more complicated scenario going on with the are we require oil for
everything.
For fucking food.
We require oil for vitamins.
We require oil for
medicine to a point.
But you also,
you're getting a lot of that from that,
that drama queen.
No,
no,
no.
I'm getting that from ground.
You don't need oil.
Oh,
Brian.
Yeah.
You do?
What?
What the fuck is going to power the tractors?
What the fuck?
Oh my,
my back yard planting.
Okay.
And then you're going to go somewhere.
I'm going to get on a fucking donkey.
I travel somewhere.
You have to take into account shipping.
You haven't taken into account travel.
You have to take into account where does everything you buy come from and what
does everything you're buying made out of and the seeds you're going to buy most
likely are going to be in some fucking packaging.
Even if it's paper,
it's going to have paint on the package that paints going to be made at all.
All right to a point.
But what if you have take point dude?
Well No,
no.
The point is oil's gone today.
Alright.
No oil left.
I also could just go to my mom.
Hey Mom,
do you have a seed?
Yeah,
I have a whole box of seeds over there.
Can I have them?
Okay,
let me take these seats in my backyard and plant
and hey man,
what's he going to get to your mom's house in Ohio,
if you know what I mean?
I'm just saying if she lived next to them,
you say,
well what if she does to me?
You got no oil Sun.
You get what I see.
Ridiculous.
Jump on a bicycle on a bicycle.
And getting my mom's tires five months.
What makes the tires on?
It doesn't matter.
I got my tires are not blown out and my story,
there's no more cars left and then blowing out.
I'll use my feet and I'll walk there.
It's going to take two years,
but I'll get some fucking sort of star because it's going to be no food.
Going to travel to get that food to you with with trucks.
Look Dude know oil ethanol well there.
That's the problem.
It's his argument about ethanol so it takes more energy to create and all the
shit of one report
out of 5,000 reports.
Well you didn't research that as I did.
I went on last night to Wikipedia because I researched it
fucking [inaudible].
It's completely,
I was up til 5:00 AM last night researching this dumb ass from this stupid
movie.
Michael Michael.
Rupert is a dumb ass.
You got official evicted by him
in his own apartment.
I know retards out and not getting evicted from their own apartment and this guy
I'm supposed to believe and he's getting evicted.
They said during the filming of this movie,
He was getting evicted.
Oh,
really?
You're getting evicted?
Wow.
My sister can't even get evicted and she makes like five bucks a day,
you know?
Yeah.
But he's not making any money.
He's trying to warn the world.
He's out there.
He falling.
He describes to the second DVD he's making.
Doesn't have a website,
isn't he?
Going nationwide and giving speeches at holiday inns.
All the hands.
Wait,
come on.
I mean,
it doesn't have like big conferences that he does speak.
He's doing them now because of the movie.
The movie is getting a lot of attention before that.
He did that too.
Yeah,
but nobody was paying attention to him back then.
I think Brian has an oil company.
Brian,
if somebody does not like him,
well I didn't have my check for sure.
For sure.
How to our country,
man.
What?
What did you say?
Just kidding.
What did you say there?
Ratted it out our country.
He's the one that ride it out.
What CIA for doing in?
In drugs.
Yeah,
so an LAPD officer,
he busted the seat.
Michael Rupert,
and he busted the CIA delivering drugs to the the poor neighborhoods,
which is fucking absolutely true.
Which is another thing like we were talking about like the Alex Jones thing,
like the Alex Jones thing where there's a guy who was right about some shit,
you know,
and he's right about that.
And he was writing about the CIA delivering drugs until these bad neighborhoods
is selling drugs.
I mean that was like a room or back then,
but that shit has been proven now.
I mean there's,
there's so many different cases where so many different,
like Barry seal's in Mena,
Arkansas,
that's not a good one.
There's people who are pilots that have come clean about it.
There's the CIA drug plane to crash in Mexico last year with four tons of
cocaine in it.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a lot of fucking money,
man.
It's a lot of money.
And if they're willing to go places and kill people,
you don't think they're willing to sell drugs.
That's ridiculous.
The people that are in charge of the government and the people at the highest
levels of government have access to all sorts of shit that we don't.
And the fact that there's billions and billions of dollars to be made in drugs
and that drugs,
those drugs are going to get sold anyway.
You know why?
Why wouldn't they sell them?
So he's right about that.
He's definitely right about that.
But this peak oil thing,
man,
he's all doom and gloom and the end of the world and no one knows there's
nothing that's going to possibly replace it.
Can you fucking say that?
Can you say that?
Yeah.
Well that guy in that Ted conference was talking about that.
We used to use wood,
but then we got used fon technology.
What have you read it?
You saw the table.
So that would now they used to be a way for us to have energy.
Now that's gone.
And now we moved to this and then we learned from that and then we move on to
the next thing.
So you were saying that what natural gas and some other type of stuff that
there's the problem is,
man,
we make so much shit with oil.
It's fucking insane.
Everything in this room is made with oil.
Your God damn computers made with oil.
Yeah,
but like everything is made with oil.
Isn't there a way to make it not with oil for the most part?
I don't know.
I think they're right.
There has to be.
There has to be like,
well,
yes,
making with oil is the best way,
but you can also make it with,
with corn.
Well maybe,
but I mean think about all the oil that's coming out in the Gulf right now.
75,000 barrels a day.
I don't know how many gallons is that?
How many gallons is 75,000 barrels?
It's fucking insane.
Insane amounts.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Hundred thousand who the fuck knows?
So 75 to a hundred thousand gallons a day or barrels a day.
Is is leaking out into the,
into the golf p person that you can make plastic with him?
Yeah,
you can.
I posted a thing today on my Twitter about a hemp car from 1941 with a from
Henry Ford,
but I don't know if you can make all the shame,
the same shit that you can make with oil.
My point is that the amount of oil that's coming out just in that one area and
the golf is insane.
Think about how long it would take you to grow that much hemp to make oil out of
it.
Yeah,
I mean fucking incredible.
I mean,
you would have to have a farm the size of the Moon,
you know?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
this shit is just pouring out into the ocean.
There's not that enough.
We need to do that in the whole world.
Not your,
how are you going to grow it?
You're going to have to have skyscrapers like sizes of like a hundred football
fields,
a hundred stories high,
and each,
each floor is hydroponics.
Each node in Detroit there they're thinking about doing that or urban farming.
You know,
there's so many areas of Detroit that there's no homes anymore dirt.
I'm talking about hydroponic buildings.
Yeah,
I'm talking about gigantic fucking buildings and even that would not be enough.
We'd only guys,
they mean,
think about the oil is coming out of the ground right now.
That's,
that's an incredible amount of oil.
When you go and you drive down to PCH to those offshore oil rigs and you think
about how many of them must be out there in the world,
how many different rigs when take that a drive from a [inaudible] get to the
airport,
you know that drive,
you see those oil rigs,
you don't think about those until some shit happens.
Well,
how many of those are out there?
How many of them are in Texas?
Oil Man do anything they don't seem like to do anything says the scientist and
it's like one little raggedy one that looks like an old farmer may put up there
in a long time ago.
That statement is how Michael [inaudible] has got to discredit you for
discrediting him.
This full doesn't even know that those things pump out thousands of barrels of
gallons of oil a day.
He said,
Joe,
I got an email from somebody from China that wanted us to talk about the Foxconn
suicides in an,
if you knew anything about that.
The Fox con suicides,
there's a huge company in China that makes a called Fox con and they make
everything like keyboard mice.
They make a lot like iPods,
iPhones.
They're the ones that put together all the computers and they're just super
cheap help.
And Foxconn,
I think,
I want to say it's 500,000 employees work at it and they all live there and they
just worked nonstop.
I mean they're talking,
they wake up,
work and go to bed and I think they only get like eight hours sleep and they'd
go right back to work.
And,
and anyways,
in the last uh,
year,
I want to say,
or with this year alone,
there's already been 11 suicides,
I think it was and 30 attempted suicides.
Holy Shit.
I guess how many employees of,
uh,
I don't know how many,
but I,
it's a lot of employees.
I want to say 500,000 kill themselves at work.
I'm not sure.
There's been people,
I want to have a pizza party or something,
you know,
on a Friday you have that many people,
Hey,
your company tried to kill themselves.
Maybe,
maybe Fridays,
casual fun day,
shirt day
about when it comes to like cheap products and cheap electronics.
I mean there's,
there's really only one way to get a fucking net book for 700 bucks.
Right?
Okay.
And that way is some dude has to eat rice out of a little bowl and sleep in a
box and he has to wake up to a whip and,
and,
and fucking do it all over again every day of the week.
And he doesn't get any days off.
I mean,
that's the only way to make that shit.
You can't make that shit with union American guys from Detroit.
You know,
it's going to take too much time.
It's going to cost too much money.
One of the reasons why you can get a net book for 600 bucks or however,
I think they're like 500 bucks,
right?
Yeah.
You can get him for two 99 up.
That's incredible.
So you can get a little fucking computer for 200 900 bucks.
I mean,
when you get on youtube,
you're like,
oh,
that's why it's two 99
yeah,
but so what dude?
Think about what you could get just a few hundred feet,
you know,
for a few hundred dollars a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
I mean that's a pretty incredible piece of technology for 300 bucks.
I can't believe how much stuff you can't buy here.
I was trying to find this company that makes scissors,
you know those orange handled junk drawer scissors that everybody has.
Right.
I was trying to find a US based company to make these scissors right then.
Couldn't do it.
I,
I've probably,
I've,
I've given up look googling it and trying to find scissors,
manufacturers and all this stuff.
It's like just huge.
It's just a pair of scissors.
Yeah.
You go to Michael's,
you got to go to arts and crafts.
Those are actually team
amazon.com by them.
I want to find a place that will produce them for
different,
not just purchase this rent to the wrong store.
Dude,
I know he was talking about people are fucking dying.
He's saying he wants to find a manufacturer.
No,
but I'm saying I can't even find that here.
That everyone I found is overseas.
So that's why it again,
no one has time here to be making scissors.
We're fucking,
how are we going to cut?
The trees are going to war and plugging up that hole and the Gulf that's pumping
out oil.
We ain't got no time.
Little fatty scissors with the rounded tips.
He little pussy
crazy about this Fox con thing in the morning.
That's insane.
The more I looked into it,
right.
So for one thing,
they only get 900 Chinese yen per month,
which is about $130.
Our uh,
our thing,
and this is working,
they get $130 a month.
Yeah.
And Shit I didn't know about how did I not,
how was I
whereabout and,
and,
and these guys are,
these guys are employed a apple employees.
I'm Sony employees and all the big guys.
Actually,
I don't want to say Sony does because I'm not 100% sure.
Told us.
I know for sure to apple does and uh,
guards beating employees.
Like there's all these like stories about this place where they have live video
of like the,
the guards at this place beating up the employees on tape to China's a mother
Fucker,
dude.
Yeah.
China is a motherfucker.
There's a billion people there.
And the bottom line about human beings is once you get into really large numbers
of us,
we lose our appreciation for each other.
I mean,
it's just,
that's,
that's how it is with rats.
That's how it is with money.
I mean,
if you have a lot of money,
fucking,
you drop a dollar,
you don't give a shit about it,
but you have $5 to drop a dollar.
That dollar is important to you.
Right.
You know,
and when,
when there's too many God damn people and you get to a point where there's a
billion people,
there's not enough food and you're literally regulating how many children people
can have because it's so overpopulated.
You know,
China has a billion people.
There was a billion people in the entire fucking world up until like a hundred
years ago.
You know,
do you know how nutty that is?
Just a couple hundred years ago,
there was no more than a billion in the whole fucking world.
Now they're all in China and who knows what the real number is,
man.
And we don't really know what the real number in America is.
We don't,
I mean it's,
it's how difficult is it to take a census of a billion people
by the way,
that the census guy hid in a,
is his car and stocked my house.
What?
Yeah.
All right.
A couple weeks ago we were talking about the census.
Remember this,
I asked you to do I have to do this and right.
Anyways,
so I came home the other night and there was this guy outside of my house
looking sketchy as fuck.
And then I just kind of like get in the house,
getting the house,
getting the house right.
And then later that night,
maybe four hours later,
I see him sitting in my car and his car outside of my house.
I'm like,
there's that same guy.
And so I'm like,
ah,
okay.
I'm just walking to my car and suddenly he gets out of his car,
it looks at me and it gets back in his car cause I got in my car,
then I came back home.
He was still there.
I go in my house,
he rings my doorbell.
He was from the census.
And did you ask him,
hey,
why the fuck were you sitting in front of my house all day?
Did I just,
I answered his questions and he showed me as,
what's a good time if I asked me,
showed me a census badge and I was asking all these crazy questions about people
that lived here April 1st I've been who lived here April 1st I'm like,
actually no one.
And then they're like,
are you okay?
And then,
but he kind of made me feel like I was in trouble and I wasn't how we're doing.
They have a right to the law.
It's the law.
The law is,
they have a right to interview and asked her all these questions at their
convenience.
I don't know,
but he was outside of my house
appointment.
Shouldn't be able to ring your doorbell.
I got shit to do,
Dude.
If you want to give you an email address,
I'll call you pretty freaky.
Oh,
give me your email address and I'll call you.
I think they're like head hunters now.
They had,
I think in California the response was so bad for the that they actually hired
like headhunters,
like private eye guys to get that filled mine out and then I got one a month
later saying,
sorry you're part of the section of is that we lost,
can you redo it?
So they lost like I filled out one twice or some guy trying to steal my identity
and just thought he'd give anything government
man,
anything with the government.
The problem with it is you've got a bunch of people for the most part that are
working for the government that don't want to be there.
That's the fucking problem with any of those jobs.
This is even worse cause I a valet.
The other day I went to the saddle ranch on sunset and I've outlaid and I just
got in the mail at a parking ticket when they vowed took my car,
they parked it in a red zone,
got a ticket,
took the ticket off the car,
I got a ticket,
I would never have known about it and I owe like $130 now.
Wow,
you should go there.
Well I told to saddle ranch and they were like,
we don't own that validates and I called the valet guy and they're like,
we don't do that.
And I'm like,
ah.
So I fouled out this whole thing with the state like a,
like a,
hey,
I didn't do this report.
Annoying or you're still responsible.
One of the most annoying and irritating things about La is that you've got a
valet everywhere.
I don't like that shit at all.
Have some dude just farting in your car and wife went through your drawers.
You ever had anything come up?
Missing?
All the time.
Yeah.
I don't.
I W if I can avoid a valet,
I never keep shit in my car anymore.
I don't have a goddamn thing and there I have gum because you want to steal my
gum goes.
They always take quarters.
They will stay that of course,
like if I have a quarters,
dimes and nickels,
I'll go back in and,
and the quarters are all gone.
Do you ask them now?
I stopped even bothering.
Wow.
You just taking the hand where the car cams don't they have where we can just
set it and we'll take it to some valets and then we'll shoot them for stealing
her stuff inside edition.
Then Chris,
Matthew,
whatever his name is,
can pop up out of the back accident.
Ask you why you have those quarters in your hand.
I'm just going to help a kid acts that they did it.
There's a really cool video of you.
Google,
NBC,
Los Angeles,
uh,
Valet car,
something like that.
Do something like that.
There's a really cool report they did.
They busted people how dude?
It was like out of 10 of
them,
they took things.
Yeah.
It happens all the time.
Show on like I'd watch that show.
I watched some bait car show the other day where they have this car that the set
up to let people steal and then once the steel it,
they're driving,
it's all Camden and then the guy can shut down the car as you drive in and
locked the guys in.
I've seen that.
Yeah.
So,
but do that with valets.
That'd be awesome.
How about just capital
fucking parking lot?
You know,
most of the places where you go to,
you don't have fucking valet parking everywhere.
It's just la is like lacking in space,
but everyone drives,
it's not like New York where they're lacking space,
but you take a cab or the subway or whatever,
you know.
No one drives New York are very few people do you know most of the people to get
around other ways.
But in la everybody fucking drives.
But there's still the same space problem.
You can't have like an expensive restaurant and a giant parking structure there.
It's too much money.
You know,
I avoid places.
If I can't park my car,
I just don't go there.
I don't,
you know,
it's very rare.
It has to be like a meeting that I have to go to or have to valet and then I'm
like,
mother Fucker,
I'll park blocks away and walk just so someone doesn't have to sit in my fucking
car.
Touch my shit.
I went in my car once and there was Mexican music playing.
I'm like,
you mother Fucker,
you found a Mexican station.
You know he went right to,
I mean I had it on satellite radio.
He switched it to am,
went right to his Mexican station.
How long is he driving for it?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
What the fuck.
Exactly.
That's a terrible part about living in la.
I remember there was a comedy club.
I used to work out where you'd have to valet and every time I'd come back I
noticed my gas was completely gone and it was in Michigan to what the guy would
do.
He'd go,
well,
he's just the MC.
They would sit in my car throughout the whole show and keep warm the heat on,
burn up all the gas.
And then when at the show was over and then they give me my car back.
Wow.
Did you say something to him?
I said something to the owner or whatever.
Then the,
I remember the guy who owned the place gave me 10 bucks and he goes,
quit your wine and gave me wine.
And it was probably about 19 years old,
which are wine and give it,
kept your car running.
I've been farting in your car,
sitting here doing whatever,
smoking cigarettes.
Oh yeah,
probably.
Sure.
And the other problem is if you have a nice car and you drop your shit off at
the valet,
look,
they,
you know,
the people that are working in valets,
they don't have nice shit.
You know,
and you have this,
I mean they're,
they're working,
they're poor.
They're either college kids they're trying to get by or they're immigrants that
are probably here illegally,
you know,
and they don't have enough money to afford a BMW or whatever the fuck you have,
Mercedes or something like that.
So what and again,
this car,
they almost feel like it.
Like,
like who the fuck are you to have this?
You know,
there's a lot of people that have that attitude.
A lot of poor people that have that attitude though that why the fuck do you
deserve this attitude?
Like I,
I remember when I was a kid,
this guy keyed this car and uh,
and,
and I go,
why the fuck did you keep that car?
It was like a nice car.
And he goes,
he gives a fuck guys are rich asshole.
I'm like,
the guys are rich asphalt.
Cause he has a nice car.
Yeah.
What a,
what
a weird attitude.
And that's an attitude a lot of people share that mentality of like,
you know,
screw the rich or the rich shocking or blah blah,
blah.
You're like,
and then I always think,
yes,
screw those guys for making goals.
Setting outcomes for themselves.
Getting educations.
I had a guy call me a rich asshole once.
Yeah.
But I was trying to fucking,
but I was trying to fucking suburban,
it wasn't even like a rich car.
It was just a white suburban and the guy cut me off and uh,
you know,
and,
and somehow or another,
you know,
he yelled something out the window and I yell,
some go fuck yourself.
And he goes,
fuck you.
You fucking rich asshole.
Like that was his,
that was a part of his insult that I was rich.
Yeah.
It would have been when somebody ran into your car recently and they were like,
come on,
you have a lot of money.
I paid for that dude.
They're girls broke.
But the only reason why I did it was because she was an assistant to someone
that I know who's a,
an executive.
But the fact that she even said that,
she goes,
yeah,
you're not even gonna miss it.
I'm like,
it's just gonna cost like 3000 bucks to fix.
But she didn't have insurance.
It was a fucking disaster.
And she was drunk.
You know,
I should've got her arrested,
but I'm like,
you shouldn't be driving drunk.
You fucking dumped sloughed.
Yeah.
By the way.
Do I say things like that to people too?
By the way,
when they hit your car,
you can call them dumps.
Sluts.
Kickass was one of the best movies I've ever seen.
It told you God,
I love that I can.
Phenomenal little girl.
Uh,
I just want to like,
I love,
I love how in the movie they actually,
even if it said something like it,
like I like how you went from someone scratches up your car.
Oh yeah.
Did a
random movie reviews by Brian Red Band.
Just thinking of her.
I haven't had macaroni and cheese in a while out of nowhere.
That's what kind of tight ship we run over here.
We stay on subject.
Yeah.
If you tried to like follow like a mind map of the subjects that we cover on
this fucking thing.
A stoner's paradise of rambles.
But I had a guy like that,
you know,
say something about being rich or,
or,
or whatever.
And it's,
I think a lot of people forget like,
well me for a comic,
I was doing standup for what,
1516 years before I made any real money.
I mean dumb and salt.
I did.
It's a dumb installed.
You're successful at the game of money and that's all that's a dumb and salt you
fucking successful.
Winner of the game of money.
It's the dumbest insult of all time because that's all it is.
And you might be successful at the game of money because somebody gave you a
bunch of chips.
You know,
you might've been born rich or you might've made it yourself.
But either way,
what the fuck kind of insult is that?
And what the fuck is it with people with when they don't have it and other
people do.
I remember Jimmy Kimmel was talking to this lady once.
He was on Larry King live,
and he was talking to this woman who had a,
um,
some sort of a service where they would give you a map of the stars houses and
they would,
she would like had an,
oh,
was a stalker website.
That's what it was.
And she would like,
they would put up updates.
Like,
this guy is here and this guy's there.
And you go like,
find out where stalker,
is that what it is?
[inaudible] dot com the Tokyo for any advertising.
Fuck that cunt.
Anyway,
she,
um,
she was on and he said,
don't you think that this is kind of dangerous?
Like you're giving stalkers the,
uh,
the,
the current whereabouts of all these people?
And she goes,
oh,
well they'll be able to cry them,
sleeps and piles and piles cry themselves to sleep and piles of money.
Like that was her response to it.
Like she didn't feel responsible even though she's putting these people in
harm's danger because they have money and like she thought it was like a valid
thing to say.
Like there'll be able to cry themselves to sleep and their piles of money.
Like,
wow,
what a weird way of looking at the world,
you know?
Yeah,
I'm going to put you in danger and a,
you know,
a deal with it because yeah,
you can deal with it.
You've got money.
Whoa.
Really?
And she felt that,
she felt like that's a valid,
valid explanation.
You know,
she felt like,
you know,
there's a lot of angry people when it comes to celebrities.
Look at Lindsay Lohan and all this shit.
If that happened to anybody else,
they'd be in jail.
And He loved Lens.
They show up,
you know,
that whole thing.
She didn't go to jail.
She has to wear this little bracelet,
you know,
even though she's lying about a passport,
even though she's lying about all this shit.
So that's why they're mad was she was supposed to go to all these drug and
alcohol classes and then uh,
she missed her court date.
Who has a fuck?
Here's,
here's,
here's what my taking the story.
She's a little kid,
little kid that got famous and rich,
like little kid that kidnapped two other people that ran from the cops.
Drunk driving was caught with cocaine was co,
you know like kitchen.
Yeah.
To people.
How'd you kidnap them?
They were in the back seat and wouldn't stop the car and she was out running
from the cops are the ones that are suing and it's like,
it's like,
like all this like crazy seven charges,
but yet she's not seeing one,
you know,
going to jail at all.
And that would happen to me.
I'll be fucking in jail still.
Okay.
Is that true or is it because of the
prison systems in La are super overcrowded.
You know that,
right?
You know that they're releasing violent prisoners secretly.
Like it's like they're,
they're having like real problems.
California is completely insight,
right?
Yeah.
I'll give you some insight info.
This girl's not supposed to be doing any drugs or any alcohol right now.
It's cause she's on probation.
Right?
I know not to rat her out.
I am going to rat her out.
Right.
Allegedly.
Don't be a rat,
Brian.
All right.
Don't you got to get her locked in a cage.
Never mind.
I won't tell us anything.
What do you know?
Do you know some shit?
I know a lot of,
she's a little kid,
dude.
If you were in that situation,
you'd be a hundred times worse.
Okay.
I will not talk about her anymore.
I'm sorry.
You Go.
Good for you.
It didn't.
She get famous and she was like fucking 16 or something like that.
A lot younger than that.
She just being that a wacky Friday or freaky Friday where he played a twin,
you know herself.
So she doesn't need middle kid.
The Disney girl.
Wow.
That's gotta be crazy man.
Go from a Disney girl to a party slot.
Internationally known party Slot Jet Setting,
ginger wearing a fucking alcohol bracelet.
So how does she a piss clean?
Uh,
I don't know.
Drink that shit.
They buy the head shop
probably stuff way.
I piss clean five times,
you know,
and I,
I'm just like,
was that poor Ohio guy and Angie,
how'd your piss clean?
Well,
otherwise a couple of ways.
There's either the shit you drink that's like Gatorade that just dilutes your
investor.
You what company?
There was a few of them.
They're all different companies.
Uh,
one was gateway,
one was,
uh,
I forget.
There's a hilarious,
his ticket master,
I think fucking pot.
Yeah.
A test you for pot.
Like you can't even smoke pot on the weekend.
If you work at gateway,
like Jesus fucking Christ will you let me enjoy my weekend.
I get off Friday.
I've been slinging shitty fucking computers for pennies all week.
Giving you most of my waking hours and you won't let me have a fucking joint on
Saturday.
I can't watch a movie.
I can't smoke a joint and go see Avatar.
Really?
They you fucking cunt.
That was great.
This one place actually sold real urine that you warm up and you put in between
your crotch.
So when you go to do p thing,
it stays warm because it's in between your legs and it's actually not your urine
and they get your urine elect.
Congratulations.
You passed the test and you're pregnant,
right?
Bum,
bum bum.
You might want to go see what kind of pistol you're going to get though.
How do you know it's clean?
Piss?
Uh,
I guess you don't,
Kevin Randleman got busted with a nonhuman urine.
Yeah.
It was either synthetic urine or it was your end from a dead person because
there was no hormones in the urine.
Like they tested his urine and they're like,
yeah,
there's no steroids.
There's no anything else either in here fucker.
Because apple juice is this shit.
It was some synthetic fucking fake urine.
They did.
He got,
you know,
I dunno.
It's persons.
Do you use the fake p four times?
They said Fake pee?
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can get,
well you know,
I think it depends on the sophistication of the task,
but some places they test your fucking hair,
dude,
the old hair sample here,
they have shampoo for that do then you just put the shampoo on before your thing
and it uh,
kills all the THC in your hand.
Does something,
well,
I know Nick Diaz passes those tests like a motherfucker and he smokes a lot of
weed and he passes.
I mean he's,
he got popped in I think,
I think you got popped in Vegas when he beat gummy.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
He turned,
turned up positive and they said that he had so much wheat and the system,
it was like he got high and then thought
he might've done that.
He says he didn't,
but you know,
he smoked so much weed though.
It's probably in a system all the time.
He probably just forgot to take whatever he does to clean himself out.
You know?
I don't know what you gotta do.
You gotta drink a lot of water.
I know that.
Right?
I have a buddy that is the medical,
uh,
he does stuff with rats and cocaine.
He doesn't get drug tested funny cause you're around every day.
He has.
And cocaine,
you know,
there's a big problem with doctors and doctors getting addicted to drugs.
There's a book called dead doctors don't lie.
And it's all about how little information doctors know about nutrition and how
little information they're given and med school about nutrition and how many of
them wind up getting addicted to prescription drugs and all the shit that can
prescribe for themselves.
You know,
it's fucking a lot man.
you think about how many doctors are out there and they're buddies
with other doctors like,
hey man,
I need a script for this.
You know,
I'll hook you up with some Xanax.
And one of the medications I got from my stomach acid,
I was supposed to be approved by insurance company because it has to get
specially approved because one of its,
uh,
things that happens when you take it,
it makes it test positive for THC.
What makes you test positive?
Wow.
Well you should tell your the insurance company that you have to test positive
for THC for your job.
He works for me and that's what I require.
I don't require a positive piss test if he's out there,
you know,
making creative shit and making videos and stuff.
I don't want them a little bit hard.
Brian,
I look your sexy a businessman jacket.
It's just a new look with the woman.
So what it is,
I had breakfast with three women last night,
really breakfast with three women last night this morning.
Eaten eggs and fucking I six at six boobs spending the night last night.
Really?
You have three chicks over your house and where they sleep?
Yeah.
Real talk.
Did I buy you and all your girlfriends breakfast this morning?
Had to really talk.
Didn't you have two other pictures over my house?
We'll talk.
Wow.
What's the difference if I found two other ones when I'm out by myself,
Brian,
what's it like going from zero to hero?
Very nice.
Tell us,
tell us all about it.
Oh No.
Did you ever think from the days of living in Ohio that you would be in the
predicament that you're at now?
Can we even say what predicament you're in now?
I'm in this.
I wasn't the same predicaments in Ohio.
Not this one.
Son for Ohio.
The ratio of Ohio.
We're not judging Shah scale son.
You want to talk about it now?
No.
Okay.
We're going to have to move on.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a touchy subject for my mayor.
I'm dating Lindsay Lohan.
No,
he's not laced gentleman.
If he was,
he would definitely not rat her out.
You'd have to be a serious cut to be date and Lindsay Lohan
and then try to rat her out.
Well,
I'm very mad at her.
Why would you be mad at?
Because I think she cheated me mean cans.
Someone checked in Cannes,
you think so?
She got a new tattoo supposedly as well for new girlfriend.
That's why I'm mad about,
so I don't care.
Wow.
You'll fuck you ass friends.
We'll talk.
I'll try it.
The fan expo this weekend.
Huh?
What's the Fanex Oh,
did you?
The UFC fan expo.
Yeah.
This weekend is a big UFC a rampage versus Rashad.
That's going to be fucking nuts.
That's a,
that's a sick fight.
Let's go to the message board to Joe rogan.net the forums and see what I said.
You were the,
uh,
the winner of season one last comic standing.
I fucked up.
But this guy sumo,
he corrected me in the fact police dat is this guy.
This is the kind questions I get weird motherfuckers.
Is it ignorant to attempt to define the universe in absolutes rather than
referring to it as a grand mystery or rather the effect,
the effort to try to define or understand fee an understandable that dude has
smelly feet for sure.
Right.
An understandable,
I'm not even gonna answer it just because of that.
You try to sneak that through.
You can't,
you can't have a legitimate question and have an understandable in that
question.
I'll talk.
You can't use it on infant in front of a word.
That's,
that shit doesn't make any sense,
but yeah.
Nobody can define the fucking universe.
It's ridiculous.
We were trying,
we're struggling.
It's impossible.
Will this be the doom podcast?
Yeah.
This is the,
um,
the,
I reject your doom podcast.
That's what it is.
It's not the Dune podcast watching that movie collapse and uh,
I got nervous after I watched it and I thought about it for a while and I was
thinking about it.
I was like,
this is a trick.
Like you can think this way,
you know,
and you can get all fucking flustered and freaked out about the world or you can
just enjoy the shit out of this.
You know,
this is some asshole that's sitting around his house saying that is his favorite
thing to do is walk,
walk his dog on the beach.
Yeah.
It's not the kind of lifted to my prime.
Lindsay shits her underwear so much.
Every time I find them in the bathroom and she has stains all over her underwear
and she's the first girl I've ever,
you think that's from drugs?
You're a 12 year old.
I was just talking about we really are fucking 12.
You're not banging.
Lindsay Lohan just shut your mouth.
Meanwhile,
his girls hotter than Lindsay Lohan.
How ridiculous is that?
That sounds like a ridiculous statement,
right?
No,
she's hot out.
That's pretty easy.
She's hot.
Right?
Ankle is hotter than Lindsay will entertain it.
Whoa.
What are you talking about?
You went bang a fucking Lindsay Lohan.
She's a mess,
dude.
You wouldn't banger.
No,
really?
I'd rather Bedfont lakes messes,
right,
don't you?
You like crazy bitches,
You like them when they're all fucked up a little bit,
right?
Well,
I mean when you're younger,
sure.
I'm really fucked up.
Or I should fear arch Felix of suicide bitches.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
He likes those jets talking about
suicide girls.
Oh,
I get you.
Those girls with all those crazy tattoos and their tits and shit like that.
Porn star Lindsey or a suicide girls.
Pornstar suicide girls.
Yeah,
those dirty bitches.
It's like bombshell McGee looking girls.
By the way,
that checks on a fucking cover of a magazine.
I was at a Barnes and noble yesterday and I'm looking through the magazines and
inked the magazine right on the fucking cover.
Is that Michelle Bombshell Mcgee?
That chick that fucked?
Uh,
yeah.
What's his name?
Jesse James.
She's so hot right now.
She's on the cover of a fucking magazine.
Just for banging some guy who's famous.
That's the answer.
I was going to be a correspondent on extra.
Wow.
Yeah.
The higher they're like,
she does like,
Hey,
I'm recording.
I'm here with a slut news.
This is what the hired her for real.
Is that really true?
Yeah.
Holy Shit Man.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Is that is really incredible.
Wow.
That's not a good thing to do man.
I think they did that before with somebody.
I don't think that's a good precedent to set.
You know,
this is what I think is going to happen.
This is my prediction that there's going to be a lot of women who like target,
like really high profile married guys.
You know,
like you know like Gosh,
they're going to get you some attention and that's a big career move.
You know,
look at all these chicks and fuck tiger woods.
If it wasn't so many of them.
There's like tiger woods bank.
So many of them that it's like they're all,
you can't keep track of them.
They're all like,
I was talking with his mistress.
Okay.
Which one were you sour then?
I worked at the Bagel Hut,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
you're like,
oh,
it's like there's so many of them.
It's,
it's,
I'm trying to think about what is another,
another example that's like that you know of that many?
Yeah,
it's like it deludes it either way.
It's like there's so many of them.
If there was only one chick that stood out,
like I know a couple of names like Rachel Yucatel and Jamie grubs.
Those are the names that I know.
Those are the only ones that I know those girls get through it.
But if there's only one of them,
that pitch would be super fucking famous right now.
Like that Rachel,
you should tell is pretty famous cause she's,
first of all,
she's very pretty and she's the one who didn't talk.
So there's all this speculation that she got paid off and Gloria Allred is her
attorney and all that jazz.
So I think,
you know,
I think chickshaw looking at this now like really fucking scandalous,
nasty bitches are looking at this as like a possible career path.
I think a lot of them are right.
What you see,
like everyone who just got busted with that dude from um,
uh,
transformers,
the guy who can make the Virgie no.
Oh Josh do how he got a,
he got a lap dance from some chick.
Remember?
Then she was on the news saying he got a lap dance with me.
It was touching my ass.
It was like hilarious to give a lap dances and not say anything.
That's the job.
But she said she fucked him.
Oh,
he tried or or something?
Yeah,
I thought she said she fucked him.
I think she said Shit.
You know who you know?
Anybody can say anything man.
That's the thing.
A guy could say fucked you.
You know,
unless you,
unless you have a video tape of all the time you were with him.
It's like,
how the hell do you know?
You know,
it's impossible.
You know.
How do you feel about the only government intervention into the BP oil disaster
is telling the people that we're collecting here to put on into hose and to use
it.
The Sop up,
the oil that already come into the marshes that they cannot use it.
Huh?
Is that true?
You know,
I don't think there's a way to clean up that oil men there.
They got a real,
real,
real big problem right now.
The surface of the oil spill is the size of the state of Maryland.
You don't have bananas.
That is,
oops.
I said,
ah,
fuck.
That's a crazy thing,
man.
To have a,
a giant oil
slick the size of a state and getting larger.
I mean,
you could see that from a distance satellite now.
You know,
that's,
that's terrifying that they don't know how to stop it.
I mean,
it literally might drain the entire 50 million barrels that's in that,
that thing that,
that,
that reservoir of oil,
that's what the estimate is 15 minutes later.
It's funny,
they were talking about Straw.
The other do the pressure of that oil coming out,
you know,
a mile underwater or however fucking deep it is.
The pressure of that oil pumping out like that to be able to contain it,
you have to have some intense fucking machinery.
You have to have some really big time,
high pressure shit.
And they never planned for this.
They have no idea how they're going to stop it.
They would literally have no idea.
And when you hear Obama talking about it on TV,
it's Ha Larry's,
cause he's just talking shit.
He's just saying,
you know,
we're going to clean it up to blow it up.
What's that going to do?
Make more oil,
more oil is going to come out,
man cave in the whole stuff.
I think part of it is they don't want to,
they don't want,
they don't want to do that because they don't want to destroy all the work.
So they're trying to figure out how to save as much of the well as they can
while figuring out how to stop it.
But in the meantime they have this giant eco disaster and they're like,
well,
we're going to take care of that.
But the problem with them taking care of that as these people can't fish there,
they've shut down like 20% of the fishing in the Gulf or at least as of a couple
of days ago.
It might be even worse now.
But all these people,
they're all fucked up from Katrina and that whole area got nailed by,
you know,
by those disasters and those just starting to get back on the road to recovery
and then this fucking thing hits him,
dude,
this is going to be an eco disaster that we have never seen before.
Sometimes it's hard to put things in perspective while they're happening,
you know,
like this is happening right now and it seems like,
it doesn't seem like a big deal because it's not affecting our ordinary everyday
life.
You know,
we're going through life and you know,
it doesn't seem like,
you know what I'm saying?
You know,
you drive to the same store,
you eat at the same restaurants,
right?
But there's a part of the world right now that is literally an apocalyptic
disaster is going down.
I mean,
it is a huge,
huge fucking reservoir of oil is pumping into the water and it's almost
impossible to get it out of there.
They're fucked.
That's scary shit,
man.
It's just not,
we're not putting it into perspective because it's not happening to us.
We're not feeling it,
you know?
So it's like,
it feels almost abstract when we're talking about it.
You know,
you see it on the news and it seems tragic,
but it almost seems abstract because it's not affecting you.
But if that was affecting us,
if we were fishermen and we were living in fucking Louisiana,
and this is what,
you would be suicidal right now,
you'd be going crazy.
You have no other way to make a living.
Do you have kids to feed?
You have no fucking money in the bank and this shit is going down.
Yeah.
And,
and things probably weren't that well off for you before it happened,
either.
You,
you know,
for the most part,
those guys are pretty,
yeah,
we're all this bailout money.
All these billions and billions of dollars,
those fucking cock suckers should be paying those fishermen right now.
They should be sending fat checks in the mail right now.
Double what they were making before so that they don't have to feel bad.
You know,
because you're,
you're killing their fucking business.
Billions of dollars to these fucks is not that much money and $1 billion would
go a long fucking way to taking care of all these fishermen.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a billion dollar industry,
but you know this,
this catastrophe is going to cost him so much fucking money.
They should take out the money for the fishermen and for the workers right now,
for all the fucking people that rely on tourism,
all the people in this kind of be big dude.
It's going to be gigantic.
And then there's the cleanup and then they're going to have to come up with new
technology to even clean that shit up.
See,
Kevin Costner had a,
had a thing that he might use.
His is what?
His hair?
No,
when he Kevin Costner and,
and I'm getting,
a lot of us are wrong.
Back when he did waterworld he got into completely overestimated how much area?
Yeah,
he got into cleaning up the ocean or the oil.
So in he spent $25 million in 15 years of research into this filtering system
that now the government is like,
well wait a minute,
you have that.
We didn't know that they're going to use Kevin Costner's.
What?
Yeah,
if you Google it,
he,
he created some thing back when he did wild world to help the ocean and now
there's,
it's supposed to like annoy the oil batteries just to do something to the oil
show.
I'm really bad oil commit suicide and you want to say,
we play the sound track from Tin Cup.
How the fuck are they going to separate that water in the oil?
I mean,
they're all talking about how they're going to do it.
Oh,
we're going to do it.
They're going to literally going to have to invent some new technology in order
to,
to just,
I can't believe they didn't have a plan.
You know?
Yeah.
Better than just what I would've done at my apartment where you just get a rug
and throw it over the spot that's on the cat litter.
It's done.
I'm not going to pay to clean.
That kept us up.
What the fuck?
They should just be other drop like the Statue of Liberty on it or something and
stop.
It's like just like
a mile underwater.
Yeah.
This is where a superhero is definitely Nivo miles underwater.
Right.
Little tiny robots that we can barely control.
You're talking about hundreds of thousands of pounds of pressure.
You know what I mean?
This,
this,
this pump,
it was pumping out insane amounts of oil and now it's just broken from an
explosion and it's pouring.
Have you ever seen the live feed?
Have you seen the live feed yet?
It's creepy as fuck.
Dude.
CNN had a live feed for a while,
but it crushed her servers because everybody was just sitting in front of it's
staring and it's just the oil.
Did slack jaw just pouring?
Well,
it was interesting because the guy that was the,
um,
one of the experts it was on CNN was explaining that from that video,
he showed that it wasn't the 5,000 gallons or barrels of oil a day.
They were estimating it was coming out.
He said it was literally like 75 to 100,000,
and he was being conservative by saying 5,000
barrels.
He's like,
it's an insane amount of oil.
Like this ain't,
this ain't 5,000 barrels.
You know,
it's like,
I'll fuck load.
Hmm.
I like oil.
It's fucking awesome when it works.
Not so awesome when it gets in your ocean,
that fleshlight oil that comes with those flashlights or you can get with this
flash lights.
It's very good.
Hmm.
Flashlight oil.
Yeah.
They have like a hot and cold and just normal.
And uh,
it's good for you even when you're not using the flashlight for using for sex.
Right.
Good for about an hour and then he fucking completely falls apart.
Well,
it's better than silence.
You're straight.
You're surfing the net.
So I'm just asking questions here,
son.
All right.
The doom and gloom.
This is what is keeping people well this is a problem and it's just like what we
were talking about with um,
with negative people online.
People gravitate towards negative stories and you know,
I mean we're,
we're guilty of it talking about this oil spill that's more of a catastrophe
than anything but this,
this,
this collapse thing because this has been a subject on my message board for the
past couple of days because the Michael Rupert Documentary and because uh,
somebody put a,
um,
a speech that he was giving and in Vermont and that was also on the message
board and that's been a subject that people been talking about.
But that's something that people completely fixate on and I'm totally guilty of
it.
I fixated on it for hours yesterday and it didn't help me at all and I'm trying
to figure out why the fuck people do that.
Why do we get so obsessed with like the unavoidable catastrophes and the
unavoidable like that,
like death.
I mean you can sit around all day and freak the fuck out about the fact that
eventually your is going to give up and quit and you're going to move on to the
next stage of existence.
Why is it though that that can stop you from actually enjoying your time that
you have?
Like what?
What the fuck?
What is it about pinball?
It's whatever you're focused on.
If you,
your brain is like a Google and you type in world destruction,
you're going to find all the links and videos and everything that has to do with
world construction and that your brain can only handle so many questions or so
many things that you're looking for.
This is one of the dudes on the message board rivalries talking about the Gulf
oil spill it and he's saying that the oil coming out as under so much pressure
that they can't cap it.
It's eroded the piping 300 feet below the sea floor and allowed oil to escape
out of the seabed at different spots.
Plus they think there might be a volcano under there.
What Duff?
Fuck Bob Kane.
Fucking Christ in the volcano has aids.
Oh my God.
Congress is going to approve a 400% increase in the gasoline tax.
There's more doom.
I want to shut that off.
I don't want to read it.
It's just loss.
No,
no.
I'm so far behind on last,
man.
Are you going to catch up?
And I'm going to eventually catch up,
but I'm,
I'm way,
way,
way behind.
So did you read anything about what happened?
No,
I don't want to hear shit,
so I'm it was it good?
I heard it sucked.
You know,
at first I was more,
I mean it was okay,
but the first time I was kind of like upset about it and now I'm kind of like,
you know what?
That's probably about as good as it was going to get anywhere.
A lot of people were bummed out about the sopranos ending and I don't have a
problem with that.
I didn't think it was the best thing in the world,
but I didn't,
I didn't feel like they fucked up.
I felt like it was just like,
how do you end such a spectacular show?
Like you got to,
it was cool how they just ends abruptly and then that that's what happened to
him.
Well No,
I mean,
yeah,
who knows?
Who knows what it is.
I mean it's open to interpretation.
Did he die?
You know,
that's the best show I think I've ever watched from beginning to end.
So Toronto's is number one to me and you see it morph and change because the
very first episode was almost like a comedy.
You remember his wife came out with a machine gun and she saw somebody who was
climbing into the window and I was like,
remember that?
I don't remember the first one.
Yeah,
it was almost like a comedy.
It's like they were,
they were playing it like not real,
you know,
they're playing it like,
like silly.
But then as the season went on and it got more and more serious than,
than as episodes,
the seasons went on,
then it,
you know,
it became this intense fucking incredible trauma.
But man,
is there ever been a fucking show that makes you so excited to see it like that?
I've never been so addicted to a show.
Is this
Ross loss was like that mean?
Yeah.
I mean there's a couple of episodes I didn't like,
but the whole getting to the end part,
I loved every second of it.
I mean I rewatched the whole entire show from beginning to end in the last three
nights.
You know what?
But I loved it.
I watched every episode just like it was the first time and I was like,
oh my God.
Cause there's all these new things now that you know certain things and you
rewatch the episode,
you're like,
wow,
that's crazy.
It is a very well made show.
Very well me,
even though I gave up on it this season,
I just got bored with it.
I got bored with it because I felt like there's so many times when they were
like guns pointed at them and Jack was like all nonchalant.
Jack was fucking phone and then man after a while Jack seems like he just gave
up.
Well,
there's a whole thing with Jack Man.
What's,
especially once you see the last episode,
you're going to think different about Jack to begin with.
Oh,
how dare you in the big,
from the beginning he was a different guy and then they turned him into a junkie
and then after they turned him into a junkie,
he seemed to be phoning it in it.
I can't tell you this,
this cause this doesn't ruin anything,
but I was kind of upset that there was certain characters and things that they
never did get to.
And I don't know if it was because of the actual actors or what,
like Mr Echo,
remember that guy?
Yeah.
Whatever happened to him while he didn't want to come back.
That's what happened.
Right.
Walt had superpowers,
you know,
and they were like,
oh,
what's so special?
Well then I read that Walt was taken off the show because he grew like three
times the height and like one season and they couldn't do that.
So they had to take him off the show.
So did they just take him off the show and forget the whole plot of him having
special powers or was there something I'm not thinking of?
Yeah,
they just dropped it.
I felt like just fucking is a problem.
Let's just never bring it up.
Ever.
Yeah.
Like this is ridiculous.
After a while they just say,
you know,
no one's going to remember.
That's whole Combo is so good.
You know?
The whole journey was good that I,
I'm not going to hate the ending because the whole show is good.
You know?
It's one of the best shows.
Okay.
It was definitely one of the best shows ever and most complicated show ever on
TV.
Most difficult to follow.
I just got bored with it after the last season.
It's like,
seemed like they were just making shit up.
Oh,
now we're going back in time again.
Boom,
I'm going to blow off a nuke and we're going to go back in time like,
come on.
Really it's that easy to just go back in time.
I could come on,
this is fucking foolishness.
There's definitely things I didn't like about it and still so mysterious and so
elaborate and so it felt like so cheap to me that that was how you're going to
do it.
You're going to,
she's going to bang on a nuclear bomb and it's going to blow up and everyone's
going to go back in time and she falls hundreds of feet down to a well and she
survives and has enough strength to bang on his fucking nuclear weapon and blow
it up.
Really?
Really.
It's like it's such a goddamn good show and you got to that
Battlestar Galactica was awesome up until the last season.
I want to see the wire.
I got boy.
Yeah,
the wires and another one that everybody recommended.
Madmen.
Dexter was awesome for a few seasons.
I got bored with Dexter.
I got bored with Dexter when John Lithgow was the bad guy.
I was like,
and he got this chicken,
a shitty rear naked choke and choked her and I was like
the real,
did he,
the last episode was last night,
right?
Yeah.
Was it good?
I haven't watched 24 since the first season,
but I was caught up after two hours and saw how it ended and went.
Okay.
I'm sure you know.
Was it good?
I liked it.
You know for an Andy like choked out as friends.
Those photo shows,
man.
The problem with those shows people choked out.
Chloe [inaudible] girl.
Really?
That's weird.
That's Duncan's old girlfriend.
Mary Lynn Duncan Trussell used to live with it.
When does she kicked him out and Duncan that a live with me for months.
It was still uncomfortable going over from when I first moved out here.
Does stand up.
Yeah.
When I first moved out here and this agent was trying to get me into the
alternative scene,
it was all those guys.
I didn't go that route,
the alternative scene,
but he was like,
you're,
you should hang out with a genie.
Graffel oh,
I was just talking with a friend of mine about that.
The alternative scene is mostly in,
in a lot of people,
so I was like,
people were trying to do smart comedy and people who are like,
you know,
trying to do something.
That's off the beaten path and they're like more nerds,
right?
That's how people like look at them.
You know,
people were proud to be nerds.
I do alternative comedy.
Meanwhile,
I can't think of more people who do that.
They pretend they don't know you thing.
Then alternative comics,
more people who are into social climbing.
Then alternative comics.
There are more Hollywood,
Hollywood then,
then the regular comics.
It's hilarious.
It's like,
what's the alternative?
The attorneys,
you're going to be ultra Hollywood.
I have seen so many comics that are alternative comics.
Do that.
Pretend I don't know you.
Um,
did we meet,
you know,
I'm the,
I'm sorry,
what's your name?
Like that fake shit that they like.
Like it's a cool thing to not know your name or something like that.
I've seen that happen with so many people.
The whole funny,
different vibe or you see a lot of these guys be very judgmental.
It the APP,
their
notebooks and all their jokes are written down and then they get up and they're
like,
yeah,
the stuff you do,
it's just not real.
It's like you,
you are totally scripted out every word you said.
You know,
even if they don't,
I mean,
I don't give a fuck of your scripted out,
or if you're loose and rambling,
I don't care.
It's like,
well,
just do whatever is in you.
You know,
whatever.
Everybody has a different style and some people tell joke jokes and some people,
you know,
they're like storytellers and some people that just shit talkers.
You know,
everyone's got their own style of doing comedy.
It's just the idea of,
you know,
yours being better,
or are you being judgemental because you know,
with,
with some alternative guys,
they don't like people who put too much energy in people were too loud people or
whatever.
Yeah.
It's like you don't,
I'd like that.
I like being entertained.
I like a guy who has a lot of energy,
you know,
like,
like a cat Williams type dude.
I,
I enjoy watching his comedy.
It's fun to me.
So like,
you know,
these guys that like that shit on people for trying too hard.
It's like,
wow,
that's like you,
you want to create this weird environment where everyone's like super calm and
like goes to whole foods.
You know?
It's like,
you know what I mean?
It's like some weird vibe that you're trying to create with alternative comedy.
So what's going on with this?
Got to see it this weekend when he's excited.
That's fascinating.
That's a good one.
So a lot of shit talking going on rampage Jackson and Rashad Evans had been shit
talking each other for fucking months man.
That's what's crazy about it.
They'd been talking shit to each other for like almost a year if not more.
I mean it happened when rampage fought Keith Jardeen and that was a long fucking
time ago and Rashad gotten the octagon after rampage.
One was talking all kinds of crazy shit.
And then of course they're on the ultimate fighter together for the whole season
and they didn't fight after that.
And then it's a lot of fucking shit.
A lot of shit happened.
They're supposed to find rampage,
how to get jaw surgery and then they're supposed to fight after the ultimate
fighter.
But rampage got a,
an awesome movie role
did his movie's about to come out to tank.
So it's going to be interesting.
Well,
I think it's going to tank.
It's the fucking a team.
It's just gonna be like Gi Joe.
You are fucking wrong.
You're going to kill how much you wanna bet.
How much do I have?
20 bucks.
I want you to feel all right,
so it has to be number one for how many weeks in a row
we number one to not tank.
It just has to not tank
just to find,
not tanking
number one.
I didn't to know what tanking means because taking to me it's like fucking
pussy.
It's 20 bucks.
We're talking about here man.
Be a man.
But what do you mean by tank?
Because by taking what I mean,
it's like it's going to get an a second place.
The first week it's out first place maybe,
but then after that it's just not tanking.
Tanking is,
it doesn't make the money that it was on a bucks.
It cost to make it.
That's what tank?
Yes.
I don't know about how much money it's going to make.
I just think that this is such a huge franchise and they're going to fail it.
I think it's going to be rotten.
Tomato score is going to be 30,
40%.
There's some movies,
right.
I look at the move and I go,
who the fuck is looking forward to this?
Like every time there's a Jennifer Lopez moving,
yeah.
Some Jennifer Lopez Romance Film.
I'm like,
fucking really,
who is running out going to see that?
Who's all excited?
There was a point in time where like Jennifer Lopez was banging out a lot of
movies and they were like big movies,
you know,
like what was the movie with um,
the,
uh,
the one with prisoners,
the George Clooney movie.
Fucking good movie man.
Do you want talking about,
was it a Coen brothers movie?
Where Brian,
but I'm trying to think of it.
No,
no,
she wasn't in that mind of yours or some movie where she played a cop and he was
a bad guy.
Oh,
the sal.
That's another cool movie that she was in with that fucking crazy dude from
just those special victims unit CSI or whatever the hell it is.
Law and order.
Vincent D'onofrio.
Did you ever see the Cell Brian?
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Fucking awesome.
Did you,
did you get the UFC video game yet?
No.
I haven't gotten a copy.
It's pretty bad ass though.
I'm sure I can get a copy comes out today,
does it?
Today's the day or yesterday or the day one of those,
but a,
it's supposed to be pretty awesome people enjoying the shit out of it.
It's supposed to get better reviews.
Then I the first one I heard
don't open that rotten tomatoes.
I saw that sex and the city thing.
That was another one.
That's another one that makes me go,
what is going on with the world that people are loving that movie,
man,
chicks are so fired up to go see sex in the city.
18 is going to suck.
How do you know it's going to suck?
Because man do anything right man.
Look what they did.
The Gi Joe fucking Hollywood,
so it's one person.
It really is when it comes to Fucker,
when it comes to retaking old like childhood dreams about iron man,
iron man,
it's fucking awesome.
You're,
your argument doesn't hold up.
Your arguments sucks.
No,
no,
I'm not saying everything.
Everything like marvel lately has been doing okay.
They did good on Spiderman.
They did okay on x men.
They did okay on Ironman,
but before that they had captain America.
They had all these horrible failed attempts.
But then when I'm talking about,
it's like the shit where they're taking like Gi Joe,
they're taking transformers and they're just fucking taking our childhood memory
and shitting on it.
Like every single movie they'd been trying to do.
Just fucking kids.
They're so sad that karate kid is a good example.
That's going to do okay,
but still it's not gonna be as good as the original.
I saw a lot of people can be CIOs complaining.
Izzy,
I saw the people complain in that he goes to China and his learning,
Kung Fu,
it's called karate,
is Japanese.
Chinese people must be fucking pissed,
but it's called karate kid.
That was a big,
they gave fucking lips to optimist prime.
Why does a robot need lips?
You are such a nerd.
I can't believe you're a grown man.
He really care about that.
Speaking of speaking of nerds,
dude
who,
uh,
was graduating from Columbia and uh,
in his,
uh,
in speech,
he,
uh,
he hacked a patent,
Oswald choke and the video got out onto the Internet.
You still want to Patton Oswald's joke in his speech.
Yeah.
And the comic,
no,
no.
That's another one.
This is a new story.
This one came out today.
Patton Oswald's joke about star Trek,
like a physics professor put a star track,
a theme to a question.
It was basically,
um,
uh,
speed and velocity equation,
you know,
and the,
the joke was that he used checkoff fires the phasers and someone came up to him
and said,
Sulu fires the phasers checkoff doesn't fire the phrase.
So I had been informed that Sulu and you know,
so the question didn't make sense and if you go in and just,
but anyway,
this guy used the exact joke.
I just fucked up that joke royally.
But this guy used the exact joke in his commencement speech and it caught on on
youtube and everyone went crazy.
It's on the Gawker,
it's on defame or all these different websites and Patton Oswald wrote about it
on his blog.
It's on the front page of his blog.
He went after the dude.
Wait,
so a guy just did it during his commitments.
That's in,
you get paid for it.
It was just him and he's just doing Harris.
He hacked it.
Who Cares?
Well,
getting paid for that.
He's just doing a speech.
Well,
patent cared.
Well that's retarded.
Is it retarded?
That's fucking retarded.
What do you think you should have done?
Patent?
Yeah,
you should have been audited.
Like,
oh,
that's,
that's cool.
I don't think he said a cared.
The guy was just doing a speech at his school.
He wasn't getting paid.
He wasn't.
These people didn't come out to see him get,
you know,
they didn't pay money.
It's not his career.
He was giving a speech when he graduated.
Right.
But if that guy is plagiarizing and his graduation speech,
what the fuck did he do throughout his college career?
If he is so brazen that he's willing to plagiarize a famous comedian on video
and he knows that shit is going to get on the internet or another college
speech,
I don't get,
dude,
everybody cares.
It's all over the Internet.
It's a big deal.
You don't want to love about it though,
that everyone's calling it.
He men see it.
It Ah,
oh,
that's funny.
That's I,
I've read that on three different places
because I heard an interview recently have been Sia and he said the first time
he ever got on stage,
he was so nervous that he went to the store and bought a joke book and took
jokes from it,
ripped out the pages and the first time you went on stage,
oh,
you're talking about the mark man pod.
Yeah.
That was very disappointing as it's like,
that's great.
Your first time on stage,
you just admitted that you stole from a joke book.
Well,
he told jokes when you buy the joke book,
don't,
don't you own those jokes.
That's right.
Not Stealing unless he stole the joke book and then talked about it.
So yeah,
I think we've said more than enough about that fucking dude.
It's amazing that people still go to see that guy though.
You have to be completely retarded or not having an Internet connection.
I mean those are the only possibilities why you'd want to go see that guy.
Comedy's a funny thing man.
It's like,
you know,
it's like all art forms kind of reflect where your head's,
you know the car,
the kind of shit that you're into.
Like I was getting tattooed the other day and while I was getting tattooed the
fucking guy on the,
the next booth was listening to this one of those metal songs like
that,
that annoying fucking screaming angry metal that sounds exactly the same.
That just reflects where your fucking head is.
That no one who's like at peace and he's like in a good place in our life,
listens to that shit.
You know?
And no one who's got their shit together would think the Carlson see.
It's funny.
You know,
you'd have to,
you have to be a mess.
You have to be,
there has to be something wrong with the way your mind works.
It has to work really poorly.
It has to be really low watt.
But there's a lot of really low want people out there.
Man.
I like the little one.
That's fun.
That's what's interesting when you,
you know,
when you see like certain things that certain people are in to certain books
that people are into and,
and you're like,
God damn,
really certain TV shows all that.
Fuck Devi.
She was awesome.
And you're like really?
Like,
okay.
I guess it is for you.
You know?
That's a hard thing to accept that I guess it is for you.
You know,
especially as a comic,
don't you find yourself like angry?
Like no,
it fucking sucks.
Like you almost want to,
I want to argue the opinion,
you know,
but it doesn't suck for them.
You're like fucking twilight,
a billion screaming horny chicks can't be wrong.
You know,
you can think it sucks all day,
but they love that stupid fucking movie.
Look at cars to one of the worst Pixar movies ever was cars in my opinion.
And they're doing a sequel to it just because they know how many people like
Nascar,
how many mid American people,
how much merchandise they can sell it based on that movie?
No.
Nascar's a number one spectator sport in the country.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
They're watching cars go around and show.
Yeah.
So you can sit there all day and go,
that's the dumbest sport ever,
or whatever it is in that or go wow.
Or there's a lot of people that are into it.
I'm just not.
How often do you go,
uh,
on the road and you're in the south and they bring up Nascar?
Like when you do morning radio,
you ever had that happen?
Yeah.
Fucking nuts.
They start talking about drivers and where the guys' shows this better jackets.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They all got my fucking Darrell.
Darrell Waltrip.
Yeah,
I get there.
Like who the hell is that guy?
Meanwhile they all know who he is.
That guy is a superstar down there.
Yeah.
It's like there's a whole different world in the south that people are not aware
of like music wise,
like country music.
There's fucking smash hit country music songs that you will never hear you.
We'll go through your entire life when you will never hear them.
Meanwhile,
they are loved by 50,
60 million people in this country.
They're not an,
it's an India.
It's not fucking foreign music from Bangladesh or Brazil or something like that.
No,
this shit is going on in Alabama and Kentucky and Mississippi and they fucking
love that music.
Brian,
remember that time we went to that place in North Carolina and what did that bar
next door?
We're in Raleigh,
North Carolina.
We were at that,
um,
Charlie.
Good nights and right next door there's a bar and the bar was playing country
music.
They were all singing along with a whole rider.
Yeah,
there's a,
they had a,
you know,
it's a funny by nickel bowl,
but that club,
that bar has an identity problem
because I have went in there and it would play country music and then it would
go from country music to rap to Jay z and then the equal amount of people would
like start dancing.
You're like,
you know what?
That's for into two really different things.
That's for the girls that like to fuck black guys.
You gotta mix it up.
Yeah.
I mean it was weird.
You're there and you get a lot of that in the soul and then you hear a lot of
like she,
you know?
Yeah,
well you got to bring the black guys in because a lot of girls like to fuck
black guys and the black guys was just not going to tolerate that country music
all day.
If you want to,
you want to bring in those little chubby white girls.
You've got to bring in some rap music for them to track some black guys to make
the mix more interesting.
I remember I was at at that particular place when I was there and I went to
shake the door guys hand and we kinda did the Roman shake by just how our hands,
you know where you grabbed the thing.
I'll never forget this shoot.
I don't know if it was a cast or a plastic thing that went from his wrist
probably down in the here.
And he had them on both sides for fighting.
So you couldn't tell him a shirt on the door guy.
So this was all like cash.
So if he,
yeah,
if he got in a fight with somebody really had an extra yeah cause I go,
did you break her arm?
He goes,
no,
I got him on both sides.
It's for if shit goes down and it was so,
seems like the gladiators were from here to here,
you know,
like a codpiece where does that forearm protection,
yeah.
Yeah,
to forums on a very sensitive area.
It's weird thing.
You want to protect the,
maybe he's a wing Chung man.
Yeah,
I think that's right.
That's why he didn't have that.
You'd think that you were blocking,
I guess that's the shit.
I hope that somebody fucking shoots.
You saw that some roadhouse stuff?
Yeah.
Well that place was like roadhouse,
man.
We were right next door.
That place there,
they had a,
uh,
the,
remember that one girl that was super awesome at Rodan,
that mechanical bull.
Like how many cowboy decks is that chick sucked.
Thousand.
Really good.
Yeah,
I've done it before.
It's hard.
I have video of you doing it on tls.
MTV,
Tlc.
No TRL.
Never done it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's not easy.
It's hard.
It's hard to hang on to that thing.
So stupid.
It's a fucking dumb way to get hurt riding bulls.
A dumb way to get hurt.
But riding a bull that's a fake bowl.
That's even fucking stupid.
Or you know,
it's like,
cause they could easily make a fig Bullock could fucking throw you off and kill
you.
So it's like,
you know,
they just make a fig bold,
just strong enough.
Just kind of hang on for a little.
That was the scariest thing that we ever did on fear factor was we have people
ride bulls.
That was the one time where I was like,
what the fuck are we doing?
There was the one time where I literally did not want to do the stunt and all we
did was like,
we just rolled the dice.
We said,
okay,
let's,
let's hope we don't crap out here.
Let's hope we don't fuck up and somebody doesn't want to get paralyzed.
We took these people that had never written bowls in their life and we threw
them on these giant fucking murderous rampaging beasts and we just throw them on
there and the guy was like,
don't worry,
these are training bowls,
and I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That's a bull that bull does know.
He's a training bull.
He does no idea.
He's a training Bullock the that thinking like,
oh,
these are the bulls they train the Rodeo guys on.
They're not as aggressive like the fuck are you talking about?
They're looking at the cage,
this things in the cage and it's fucking bouncing back and forth and slamming
into the bars.
We took this girl on,
she weighed 90 pounds,
like no bullshit.
She was tiny the most,
she weighed like 98 okay.
She's like five feet tall.
She's a tiny little girl.
She gets on this bull and the think box and she goes full lying.
I mean instantly goes flying and as she's flying the book kicks adder and the
Bulls Hook just misses her face,
like just misses her face.
It would have caved her fucking monkey head in like no question about it.
This poor little girl,
she fell and landed on her back.
She got knocked out and you know,
she came,
she was,
she was conscious but she was like out of breath and she couldn't,
you know,
the breath got knocked out of her and she was all like,
Ugh,
oh I'm okay.
I'm okay.
And they had to like take care of her and there the,
the,
the paramedics had to check her out and make sure she was fine and she just
lucky that she was fine.
Just plain fucking lucky.
Those I got to see those bulls.
My wife was on a show right years ago
that nobody saw called America's toughest job in what they did is every week
they did something else.
So she was on the deadliest catch boat and had to do that stuff.
And then she was a,
um,
an oil rigger and had to go do that stuff.
Then the log stuff.
And she had a thing where one of the episode,
she was a bull fighter,
so she was the clown that got in,
in an actual Rodeo is the thing.
And so when the bull buck,
the guy,
she would have to run up and it was,
these weren't fake polls.
It wasn't like for things she had to run up and literally smack the ball to get
the bull to chase her cause she was getting on the show was getting graded on
how well she made the cowboy safe.
And she blew out her knee twist and turn and it's like a lot of dirt.
It was pretty scary.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Just to be on TV.
Yeah.
And she did it,
you know.
Should she make money off that show?
No,
but she did some cool stuff.
She got to drive the grave digger and some over cars.
She blew her fucking knee out for free.
Yeah.
So I mean she,
you know.
Wow.
She didn't make I,
like I said,
it was pretty good.
It's one of those shows she had to do that fishing thing though.
That just looks shitty.
Yes,
she did.
She got a truck driving license and drove the ice road.
Scary as fuck.
She had a really good at all that.
She didn't make any money.
Hmm.
Oh Man.
There's got to be on t v eight a reality show money every month.
I think she,
I think she got a stipend every week.
500 bucks.
Cash was nuts.
It is nuts and do that to you.
They getting use you like that on television over a course of like,
this ain't like fear factor where you're only on it for a couple of days now.
She was on it for how long she was gone for two months.
Cheese.
She did like nine episodes.
So one episode a week probably.
Dude.
What up?
She got killed by a bull.
Oh,
you should see all the stuff that he,
yeah,
she got killed.
How would you have felt?
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
You can't even sue.
You can't even do anything about it.
Dude.
Bowls scare the fuck out of me when I see that running with the Bulls in Spain,
you know,
there was a show once where they,
uh,
they wanted me to go running with the bulls.
I forget what it was,
but uh,
they,
there was like one of the things they wanted me to do on the show and I was
like,
what are you talking about?
And they're like,
the people run with the Bulls all the time.
He just gotta make sure you get ahead.
I'm like,
those are his and beer soaked fucking streets.
People are tripping.
Have you ever watched videos?
Fuck you.
I was like,
you want me to go run with the Bulls?
Like what's an ancient tradition?
It's one of the dumbest ancient traditions ever.
The fact that people still do that today is one of the most,
one of the weirdest fucking statements about human beings.
You take a bunch of rampaging,
monstrous beast animals.
They,
have you ever seen the videos to dudes getting jacked?
They just get thrown through the air.
Like they're nothing.
Like these things are so fucking strong.
And they stopped them and Gorham,
I mean,
people get fucked up.
They get really,
really fucked up by these things.
Man.
The fact that people are still doing that,
man.
You see the video,
the a matador last week,
they've got the,
um,
the horn through his face,
through his mouth,
and uh,
through his,
at the bottom of his chin and now through his mouth is fucking horn is poking
out of his mouth.
That's the image.
So I saw that and I said,
well,
I seen one before that was more fucked up.
There was one that were a guy's getting it through the stomach and the bulls
like lifting them through the air.
It's like just lower abdomen,
like right above his dick.
It's the most,
because of the look of pain on his face.
He just,
he knows he's fucked.
I mean,
he's just done.
And so I started looking at Google search,
trying to find that image and I found so many fucking images,
guy him dudes,
most of it's the running with the bulls though.
Most of the images came from running of the Bulls.
So many guys getting fucked up by animals.
Brian,
you went to the La Zoo,
Huh?
Uh,
yeah man,
that was the worst zoo I've ever been to.
And one of the just fucking creepiest as there was so many cages that look like
the animal died and they just never bought a new animal to put in there.
So it's just like,
like empty.
And you're sitting in there trying to find the simple animal and you're like,
wait a second,
this is the cage has not even been touched for five years.
Like,
and then,
uh,
there's just,
I didn't see one lion.
I didn't see an elephant.
Uh,
no,
no.
I just went there.
I was sober and I went through the whole thing and like two hours.
It was like so fast.
It was the worst zoo ever.
The only cool thing was,
it's not as bad as the one I told you about in Massachusetts.
There was one that they shut down.
There was,
it was horrible.
They had this,
this little tiny ass cage for this lion and the lion would just walk around in
circles,
looking depressed,
walk around in circles.
The coolest part was when they fed the chimpanzees and there's like six of them
and they are just all lined up,
you know,
sitting next to each other,
itching their butts,
you know,
and they're all eating.
They all grabbed,
uh,
what is that?
Cucumbers and they're all just had like four cucumbers and one was like acting
like he was smoking.
Oh,
hey look,
it was just hilarious because there were just like humans and they're all just,
but within there,
like not sitting like on,
it was called the chimpanzee pin house or the eight pent house
and it's like they were just sitting like on stairwells.
So there's just all these monkeys sitting on stairwells eating cucumbers and it
was just the oddest thing ever.
That zoo is fucking weird.
It's very strange that we feel like it's okay for us to take intelligent
animals.
Just lock them up so we could stare at that.
I that I don't agree with that.
I mean that,
that zoo,
I agree with you on that.
Cause that zoo,
I don't agree with that.
Zoo z should be torn down.
Uh,
I was,
I'm used to Columbus Zoo where a monkey has like acres and acres and acres of
just grass and San Diego's great shit like that.
Yeah.
That's one of my favorite zoos in the cuts.
A huge ass.
Do you know,
they have a lot of space to roam around,
but la zoo,
we'll get you,
they'll get you off zoos.
They see on the chips.
Should be illegal man.
I was in Colorado at the zoo and this fucking champ was screaming,
screaming in agony.
Wasn't chimp,
was a monkey who was in his cage and screaming in agony and you could hear it in
his voice.
He was fucking tortured.
He was stuck in this little box by himself and people would just walk by staring
at him and he was just losing his mind,
just screaming.
It was such a tortured sound.
I mean,
are we really getting that much out of these fucking guys being locked in this
thing that it's okay to do this,
but you got pictures.
Oh Dude,
there's this one eight that was,
there was like a red a and he looks so sad.
Yeah.
Yes.
An orangutan rang a Tang and he was so sad.
His eyes are just like so depressed.
But then his son came up to me,
why was filming and just start slamming the window,
like,
don't record my dad.
Well,
there's one who's staring out of,
yeah,
that's got to suck,
man.
They're intelligent.
I mean,
they're not nearly as intelligence people,
but is it okay to lockup retards?
You know what I mean?
At what point in time,
if we could prove that a monkey was as smart as a a down syndrome person,
would it be okay to put the down syndrome person in jail next to the monkey?
You know,
I mean how,
how intelligent they have to be to where we can't lock them up,
you know.
So I said if we ever found big foot and everybody thinks big foots all cool and
everything and you know,
he watched it on monster quest.
Wow.
I wonder if it's real.
If it was real,
he'd be locked up right next to that fucking Orangutang.
You know,
we wouldn't,
as long as we can't understand your language,
fuck you get in the cage.
Vivid would have a porn video with the big thing.
So,
and Kendra,
Kendra,
Brittany,
sky,
Britney,
Scott,
your video.
But you know what I'm,
my girlfriend was telling me about that Kendra video.
You've heard of it,
right?
What?
Kendra?
Yeah,
there's a sex tape that came out before Hefner.
Hefner dated her when she was 18 so it must have happened like the first two
months is with the w e c fighter.
How do you know that he wasn't banging her while she was with halftime?
Right.
Seems more like,
yeah,
but suppose there's
those girls.
Don't all fuck them exclusively.
That's ridiculous.
It's supposedly this failure was before Hefner though.
The whole fucking Hafter thing,
man.
Poor fucking girls.
Those poor sad girls that fuck that guy to try to get famous.
They had to be,
they couldn't leave the mansion after 90 9:00 PM that's hilarious that he would
still try to keep them from getting fucked by other guys.
He had know it was going down.
Do you follow him on Twitter?
No.
Wow.
It's so sad.
Is it?
He just his uh,
Hugh Hefner's Twitter is,
every day is just like,
it's just rewatched.
Oh yeah.
It's totally him.
Just rewatch.
Gone with the wind.
I love that movie.
Just rewatch Tutsi.
Oh,
those crazy guys.
Every that's,
he just watches old movies all day.
That's all he does when he's a hundred years old,
bro.
How old is he?
He's deep in his eighties right?
Yeah.
Late eighties it's amazing that he's still got to keep that thing going.
You know?
He's got to still try to keep that at the end of that fascinating fucking
lifestyle.
What point do you just go,
you know what,
everyone just get out of the mansion please.
I want to hang around and be bold.
You stopped doing that though.
You started dying.
Yeah.
You know,
keep the business going.
Right.
I just went to an estate sale the other day.
Somebody died down the street and estate sales where they just kind of opened up
their house and you just buy anything you want.
Like everything's for sale,
you know,
get the fuck out all the shit out of the house and just walk in and say,
I'll give you 50 bucks for that.
Right,
right,
right.
And it's so crazy because they just like the guy died and he did not touch
anything.
So it's like how the guy died.
That's how it was house look like.
And it's just so crazy just seeing how this person lived.
You know?
Like,
like how dirty this person was.
And just like how creepy it,
what was it like?
I guess it would be,
it's really hard to explain like,
like as an example,
like his chair,
the side of his chair,
it was just like stacks of like TV guides from the last 40 years maybe.
You know.
And they all had like crossword puzzles to motherfuckers out there like we were
talking about that Michael Rupert Guy.
Imagine if he can be a fly on the wall in his house.
Him hanging out with his dog.
By the way,
one of my favorite quotes from that was,
uh,
that is when he goes,
I need,
I take my dog out to go walking every day and a half a smile closer.
That was going to bring that up,
dude.
The fucking world is ending according to you.
You asshole.
You're out there collecting smiles.
Yeah,
he sees how much know he can make smile.
Who he looked like.
Remember on office space,
that guy that made the jump to conclusions floor mat.
He looks exactly like that guy.
Jump to conclusions.
Floormate.
So Google search jumped to conclusions,
floor mat,
office space,
and look at the photo.
And then Google route,
whatever the guy's name is Rupert,
same guy.
This guy said it was the Corey Feldman sale.
Corey Feldman.
Still Alive,
sir.
Done the handsome Corey.
Poor little fella.
Yeah.
So another one,
childhood stars.
Just like your girl Lindsay.
It's so fucking speaking.
Impossible grind man being famous as a trial.
And then what happens,
you know,
with the Disney channel,
now look all the future of those guys that,
that channel's cranking out.
Yeah.
No Shit.
It's a puppy mill for future Danny Bonaduce.
That's a great way to put it into a puppy mill.
It really is a puppy mill.
You're dead right?
You all live in this to look a lake Renee.
I think they've supposed to live there.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause it's right near Disney.
It's right next to him.
The Disney.
And they all
live in Toluca lake,
the Jonas brothers.
Uh,
what any of them,
I don't even know any of them.
So we got it down to a science over there at Disney and they know how to make
fucking stars.
Yeah.
They take a chick who could sing and they just fucking make them dance as your
sitcoms.
They can wear promise rate and those sickos mostly we have a sister who bid ass.
Fuck.
Did you see the video of Miley Cyrus given some 40 year old guy a lap dance,
but she was like 16 and her dad's like,
Hey,
your kid's going to be willing to Gainesville be you fucking don't Burke,
my fucking dad,
Billy Ray Cyrus.
You know God.
If that was my daughter,
I'd be horrified.
I would be sick to my stomach.
16 years old,
given a 40 year old guy,
a lap dance.
He doesn't give a fuck.
You got a second chance at stardom by him driving around in a Ferrari for
probably he used up all that Achy breaky heart money.
But this fucking Miley Cyrus money,
the Hannah Montana money ain't going nowhere,
son.
That shit will take him to the grave.
Ladies and gentlemen,
five 41 that means a,
we've been doing this over an hour and a half,
two hours.
It's two hours.
20 minutes or 15 minutes.
That's too much.
I'm sorry.
We had a run out in the beginning and grabbed the microphones,
but I know that shit sounds much better with the microphones on,
correct?
Oh,
totally.
Yeah,
so glad you enjoy it,
John.
Half.
Ron,
what do you got going on?
You want to plug?
All right,
nothing going on,
but people go to John heffron.com they have all my dates.
They have problem with two F's,
two F's.
John with an h.
Dot.
J O,
h n h e f,
F r o n.com.
The bottom winner of last comic standing.
Oh yeah,
add is Twitter.
It's right there on the little screen there,
but if you're on iTunes,
you don't know what the fuck we're talking about.
If you're one of those strictly audio only fellows,
then if you're an iTunes and type in John Heprin and search and look it on mine
and you're missing what the beauty of the experience of the Ustream podcast
because the eastern podcast has facial features,
costumes and see when someone's checking their phone or on my girlfriend on a
paper to Kona fanning.
Anyone else knew it?
What the fuck are you talking about?
What's wrong with you?
Boy?
So sad man.
Um,
uh,
thanks for tuning in.
We'll be back next week,
same time.
We've got the sound down now.
And uh,
now that I finally got the last microphone in today and that's why we had to
take off at the beginning.
I thought I had a third one,
but I didn't have the,
uh,
the microphone cord.
So now it's all set up.
We're still trying to figure out what the fuck to do behind us.
Uh,
the green screen setup is not as easy as I thought because not only do I have to
get a tri caster,
but I also have to get fucking lighting in here.
It's not a banner like just to cool your alien e d three d Samsung.
No,
no,
three d stupidity.
If I'm going to get a TV,
it'll just be regular TV,
but that doesn't even make sense because we're talking,
you know,
and it's like,
cool.
If we did it and we had space behind us,
those TVs,
I could hook up our computers to it and could just be a huge as monitor TV.
This stupid computer doesn't even have an htmi out.
You know,
that's the thing about lap Apple's computers as opposed to like a pcs and,
and,
and he sees
if so many more outputs all you have it display adapter and all you do is get a
display to htmi adapter on Ebay for $3.
Well why not the hell they have a fucking outlet built into my goddamn laptop
sun because it's a smaller uh,
output.
So it's,
I mean it isn't there a video out?
It does with what video out?
It's on the side.
It's a mini display adapter.
Oh,
that thing.
And you just get a,
a mini display adapter to htmi.
So we would do that and put it behind us.
Then what will we put on it?
We just have it as a second monitor behind it.
So you have that,
you want to show a video,
you just drag it to the mill.
I guess we should,
when we should be talking.
We should have just nothing but car accidents.
Totally know.
I kids will have episodes like this week it's going to be,
the problem with the green screen is we can have video,
we have images and that's not as cool.
You could do video,
you can do anything you want to behind this is that the green screen is just
like old technology.
Why not have a huge L LSD?
D's Are so cheap nowadays.
It's just have a crazy big LCD.
That'd be a hundred times better.
No,
it wouldn't though because if you had a green screen we could have like fucking
monsters get a green.
If we get a green screen,
we'll get that stupid clipping where one of us will have like green hair.
You know?
It just looks shitty.
Does it?
Yeah.
Do you think it makes treated John Green screen technologies?
Not yet.
John [inaudible] good,
good stuff with the Green Tree Inn and then you could plug clipping apparently
from the lighting the,
if you have lighting.
Green screens are pretty tough.
If you have,
you have to have power lighting in here so we'd have to flood ourselves.
None of us could wear a green tint of a shirt.
Well today and we'll be fine.
We'd be golden.
Yeah,
we'll figure it out.
But the sound issue is done.
The video issues done.
We change cameras.
We uh,
also the host uses Ustream producer thing now.
So we have the option of having these uh,
HD cameras broadcast a show.
So,
uh,
that's the next step is we're going to set up more than one camera cause right
now we're all in this one couch,
like three monkeys.
But uh,
but I have it set up so that there's another chair over there.
So I wanted like this Webcam Dro.
No,
keeps on going in and out of focus.
Right.
It's the autofocus.
I wonder if that's a setting.
I don't think it is.
Who gives a fuck?
All right.
Ladies and gentlemen sometimes were blurry.
That's been the show this week.
It's five 45 and a that's more than two and a half hours.
So,
uh,
thank you very much for tuning in.
We will be back next week,
same bat time,
same bat channel,
Tuesday as it were,
or Wednesdays I yelled at my manager and,
um,
we'll see you motherfuckers.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Thanks again for everything.
Thanks for all the constructive criticism.
Thanks for coming to the shows.
I'll be in Canada soon.
Uh,
I dunno know the dates sometime in June.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
It's all up there.
Next big show in,
in America is in Vegas.
House of Blues July 2nd.
See You bitches there.
I don't know who's coming with me at this weekend.
Universal Aaa.
No,
no,
no.
Shows this weekend.
Thank you very much.
Every day,
buddy.
We'll see you next week.
Right.